Hey,
you fuckers,
what are you doing?
Uh,
got to meet the Squarespace people this weekend,
uh,
in Manhattan with the Great Tony Bones bones in the house,
ladies and gentlemen,
and a,
they couldn't be fucking cool.
They were exactly what I thought they'd be a bunch of.
Does that mean a bunch of smart looking young cats and very cool guys?
It was really fun.
It was a New York was fucking fantastic.
God Damn,
that was fun.
It's a great time.
Whoo.
It was fun in so many ways.
I fucking show was intense that the show.
Well,
we'll talk about that later,
but the Squarespace guys were cool as fuck.
And it's always nice when you,
um,
you have a sponsor that not only you believe in,
but you meet the people that are behind the sponsorship,
the company,
whatever,
and they're really cool.
Uh,
and they were super happy too.
You could tell that their product is actually awesome,
that so many people use it and enjoy it.
Uh,
what Squarespace is a website that allows you to make your own websites super
easy to do.
If you can do any of the normal functions on your computer,
drag and drop and Click and point and all that shit,
you can make a website.
A Kara Santa Maria was on the podcast last week,
runs her website through Squarespace.
She was talking about how easy it is for her to organize all of our media.
If you've got a store,
you put an online store up super quick and easy with Squarespace,
they have awesome support.
24,
seven,
if you're confused and you can't figure out what to do,
they can help you through it.
And they,
they also have it so that if you're a musician,
you could sell music on your site.
You can,
it's,
there's so much cool shit about Squarespace and the most beautiful thing is I've
never heard one person say that it's not awesome.
I love it.
I love Squarespace has use it.
Well.
I've,
um,
I've been to the side a lot and,
I work with them too and I feel like it's a,
the thing that I always think about is the fact that in today's Day and age,
it blows your mind when someone still doesn't have a website.
If you have this as a tool,
like it just makes sense.
Like no matter what,
if you cut grass,
yeah.
It's like,
why wouldn't you have,
hey,
go here and you'll see me and contact me here and see what I do.
You have no excuse to not have a site so easy.
Yeah.
We gave away for a different one year memberships to Squarespace and for new
hire primate tee shirts,
which have all been restocked.
The higher primary t shirts been restocked.
I'm sorry,
I'm slow with that shit.
Um,
but uh,
I'm a busy little boy now,
uh,
for a free trial and 10% off your first purchase at Squarespace,
go to squarespace.com enter in the code,
Joe.
That's it.
Just Joe.
And remember when there was numbers behind it.
Apparently not anymore.
They give up.
They realized that shit is ridiculous.
Joe.
One Joe to Joe Three Joe,
stop.
One joke.
I'm Randy.
There's plenty of Joe's.
That's not true at all.
It's like God damn pilot with them.
That is the most overused name in the world,
probably right next to one
was that the world of podcasts,
there's one judge oh
was two or three.
That's why you're here.
Uh,
go to squares.
Bailey's and uh,
they have also launched a logo creator.
We can create a clean,
simple logo.
Design yourself in minutes.
How fucking awesome is this website and could it get more awesome?
I say it can't.
So go there and enjoy Codeword Joe,
we've also been sponsored for quite a while now by legal zoom,
another outstanding website that makes it so easy to do shit that you used to
normally struggle to do.
Like any sort of a legal issue,
incorporating forming an LLC or making a will,
all those things.
You used to have to go to an attorney probably more than once.
You'd have to fill out a bunch of paperwork,
pay a bunch of money,
way cheaper,
cheaper,
cheaper beer.
That's a new word to do on legals.
Legal Zoom,
legal zoom.
You can form an LLC starting at $99 that's outrageous.
If you think about how much fucking time it takes to actually go to a lawyer's
office,
drive there,
Park,
take the bus,
whatever the fuck you do,
get out,
go in,
sit there,
go throw the bullshit,
pay a stupid amount of money and then go home.
That's all that can be eliminated simply and easily.
For 99 bucks on legal zoom,
you can protect your family with a will for just $69 and get a living trust
power of attorney.
They get the job done right ladies and gentlemen,
nine at a 10 customers would recommend the service to their friends and family
and you know that.
I know that one out of every 10 people is a fucking idiot for sure.
At least that accounts for that one out of 10
Ooh,
click.
You can do it for me.
Ooh,
is this clever marketing?
Look,
it says here you gave the person a legal plan and like that's for babies,
but a business legal plan that's for adults and that is interesting.
I would think that that's actually for family.
That's how I would look at it.
Do you need a will though?
You need a way.
If you're,
if you don't have a will and you're an adult,
you know you're going to die.
Well,
the government just says we'll take it.
Just snatch up most of your money.
Didn't you?
Gotta fuck it.
Scrapped for it and figure out who,
who deserves it.
Yeah,
that sucks.
Right?
Like they get to top it off with the actual laws are,
as far as I'm saying,
the government scratched his up all your money.
But I know they definitely get a little bit.
Yeah,
I don't know how it works.
It's,
you know,
it's fuck man.
What's really fucked
is inheritance tax,
which means that say if you Tommy bonds leave behind a child,
uh,
some money,
like say one day you're a wealthy man and he got to tie you work your ass off
and you love the shit out of your kid.
Your kid wants to be a surfer for
whatever the fuck can you like,
how to give my kid all my money?
Well,
you kid doesn't get all your money.
The kid gets the money that is left over after he pays taxes on the money that
you already paid taxes on,
right.
It's money that you earn.
Is that a state tax?
Is that what that is called?
Yeah,
it's creepy.
It's just I would like a piece.
But you had your piece.
Yeah,
this is all clean money.
It's like if a guy gives you $100 he says,
Tommy,
I like you and I know you would want $100 I'm gonna give you $100 do you really
have to report that for earning and do you have to pay taxes on that?
That's a gift.
Like what are you doing?
You creepy cuts.
You know,
like,
you know when someone's working for someone and someone's not,
you know when someone's actually getting a paycheck or someone's getting a gift
and you know that inheritance is money that somebody already fucking paid for.
Man,
if you want to leave your kid $10,000 and it turns out to be,
you know,
6,000 why not?
Why isn't it 10,000 why do you get for you fucking creed?
It's changed hands.
So we get it,
we get paid again.
They've doubled t double tap.
That's why you need to leave your kids money in bip bitcoin.
Now you need to leave them better than shut down without stumbling or maybe cash
in a mattress.
We stuff it in there.
Yeah.
I mean I have a hole in the ground with a fucking vault in it.
You know?
It's just,
it's,
it's bizarre that people think it's okay to pay taxes on something twice and
every,
you know,
here's another issue too,
when it comes to taxes and inheritance and shit,
people who are broke,
there's a lot of people that are ambitious and they're hard working and the
struggling and trying to put it together.
But there's a lot of also people that are broke that are cunts and they want
everybody else to be broke too.
And they think that somehow if you pay more taxes,
it's going to help the economy or help them or no,
it's not.
It's going to give money to some fucking people that are going to be in
competent with it.
Let's be honest about what the fuck's going on with your taxes.
This is not like an to fix the fucking homeless problem.
It's not going to fix the school system.
If you take 10% of this guy's money that his dad left him,
just stop.
You're stealing,
you're stealing and you're throwing it into and competence system that has
nothing to do with legal zoom.com legal zoom.com the past 12 years has helped
over 2 million Americans and they've saved a ton of money.
They're online process could not be easier and they will take care of you from
start to finish and you get a special discount from listening to this podcast.
Make sure you enter Rogan in the referral box at checkout for more savings.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but they can connect you with a third party attorney and provide you with self
help services.
The third party attorneys is really important.
They're independent attorneys that they can connect you with.
So if you freak out and you're in the middle of filling out this shit and you're
like,
God damn it,
I can't do this.
They will connect you to a lawyer,
which we're going to have to do in the first place before you found out about
legal zoom,
but most likely you're not going to need it.
You're not one of those one out of 10 are you?
You fuck wit.
Anyway,
go to legal zoom.com and see how they can help you out today.
Use the code word Rogan.
Uh,
we're also brought to you by [inaudible] Dot Com it's o.
N.
I.
T.
We are a human optimization site.
We sell you the best shit we can find,
whether it's protein powder or supplements like digest tech and a digestive
enzyme supplement,
or the the finest hemp protein powder we can get.
We sell all shit that I think can be used to benefit your life,
to optimize your health,
to sharpen your focus,
to heighten your mood,
to make you feel a little groovier,
to give your life what it needs on it.
One eighties,
one of my favorite things that I take with me on the road every time and it's a
nutrient based rejuvenating energy drink mix.
I mean when I say energy,
I don't mean like like a speed.
It's like Alpha brain.
It's got a bunch of different shit in it,
but it's got shroom tech,
it's got five HTP from new mood.
It's got the um,
neuro,
all the neurotransmitter support of Alpha brain with a bunch of different shit
into it as well.
That's great.
When I travel,
when I do,
um,
you fcs or something and I have to spend a lot of time on planes and uh,
also working out when I'm there and dehydrated and you know,
God forbid if you're out drinking,
uh,
this will help.
It will help in a big way.
Give your body the nutrients it deserves,
ladies and gentlemen,
it will change your life.
There's a lot of fucking talk online from a lot of salacious headlines about
multivitamins don't work.
When you look into those multivitamins don't work claims.
What you find is that the test that they were using in order to determine that
multivitamins don't work,
we're really ridiculous.
What they're doing is they're saying that people who are over 50 65 who have had
heart attacks don't benefit from multivitamins,
synthetic multivitamins,
that's essentially one of their main port up points of their study.
Their study had three parts to it.
It's really bizarre study.
One of them was that they showed that high dose multivitamins had no effect on
the progression of heart disease and heart attacks a virus.
The other one was the male physicians over 65 showed no improvement in cognitive
decline using generic multivitamin supplementation.
So what they're doing is they're taking people that are really fucked up already
and dying old people that giving them multivitamins that are synthetic,
generic,
but they're,
and they're not showing improvement in cognitive decline.
Well,
let's be honest,
first of all,
and when someone's having cognitive decline,
it's over.
You're not going to get younger.
You're going to get older.
There's almost nothing that improves cognitive decline in people who are old and
they're falling apart.
Almost nothing unless there's some new miracles that come out.
So what they're saying is essentially vitamins can't do miracles.
They can't do any of the miracles of modern science.
And modern medicine hasn't been able to do it either.
There's no medicines that they can give you that slow cognitive decline in old
people.
I mean,
you can maybe cut out a few things in your life that you're doing that are
hurting you,
like drinking or cleaning up your diet,
giving yourself less inflammation.
There's a bunch of things you can do to slow down the process,
but when you're fucking dying,
your fucking dying,
you know you're falling apart.
So for someone to make a study saying that vitamins don't work and they're a
waste of money based on these,
that shit is so irresponsible.
It's so irresponsible.
And this is coming from,
we don't even sell multivitamins.
You know?
I think that the best vitamins that you can get into your body are the closest
to how nature intends them.
Meaning food based vitamins,
things that are based on the nutrients that are based on actual food,
not synthetics and synthetics I'm sure are better than nothing.
The idea that they're not as ridiculous.
The idea that there's a reason why they know that vitamin C cure scurvy prevent
scurvy.
There's a reason why they know that when you have a lack of calcium,
your body can get osteoporosis there.
They've no,
this is all facts and science.
People love to shit on things that are controversial when they do not have all
the evidence.
They love to be a naysayer.
They love to call bullshit and they love to call bullshit when they're fucking
wrong.
And with,
with vitamins and supplementation,
I think they're wrong in a huge way.
I prefer to get my vitamins,
I take a lot of different nutrients and a lot of different vitamins,
but I prefer to get my vitamins mostly from like green drink powders,
powders that are essentially dehydrated greens.
Um,
we sell superfoods on,
uh,
on,
it's called,
we call them earth grown nutrients on,
um,
on a.com.
And it's based on that idea,
based on the idea that the things that are the closest to what you eat in the
real world,
if you have a healthy diet or they're going to be the things that your body
digest the best.
And what we have in this,
in this,
this super food power,
food,
um,
combination is first of all,
we,
we have various Greens,
we have antioxidants,
the Greens that we have all these earth grown nutrients.
It's essentially food that did just take the water out and all the nutrients are
left.
Is it as good as eating fresh vegetables?
Absolutely not,
but it's close.
It's close enough so that if your diet is off,
if you're not getting enough vegetables,
if you're not getting enough raw nutrients and minerals,
you're going to have a much better time adding something to your diet.
Then just allowing your body to be in that sort of a situation where it's at a
deficit.
Um,
we're going to have some,
some doctors on some scientists and the in the near future that are extreme
advocates for multivitamin supplementation.
And we've had many conversations with these people because of,
uh,
these,
sort of salacious headlines that people are really pissed off because they've
seen some improvement in their patients and with various things.
I mean,
there's been several studies that have showed an improvement in preventing
infectious illnesses,
uh,
improvement in mood and stress,
cognition,
work,
stress and even juvenile delinquency and noted help multivitamins.
And this is not,
these,
these are not like bullshit studies on,
you know,
fucking the daily mail or some shit.
These,
this is all on like pub pub med sites.
These are all like published papers and the effect of Multivitamin and mineral
supplementation on juvenile delinquency amongst American school children,
a randomized,
double blind placebo controlled trial.
So shut the fuck up about vitamins don't help you because they do,
they're there.
They are the building blocks of life.
They are nutrients there what you need in order to live your life optimized.
Okay.
And,
uh,
obviously I'm not a scientist and obviously I barely get through the shit that
I,
I do understand.
But the reality of all this stuff is that the more healthy nutrients you get
into your body,
the better your body's going to work.
It's really that simple.
Uh,
use the code word,
Rogan,
R,
O,
g,
a,
N and you will save 10% off any and all supplements.
One of the key points about on its supplements is we have a 90 pill,
30 day,
100% money back guarantee.
You don't even have to return the product.
If you try something like Alpha brain or shroom tech and you don't like it,
you just say you don't like it and you get your money back.
You can't just keep doing that every month.
He's silly bitch.
But the idea is that we're selling you something that we believe in so much that
we want to make it as accessible as possible.
We want to make it so that when you,
when you have this relationship with us,
if you're,
you're buying the supplements,
you feel like this is,
this is good.
This is a,
an ethical good way to do this.
They sell me something at a reasonable rate that is the best stuff that they can
find.
And if I don't agree with it,
I get my money back and that's w w no one does that.
And the reason why we do it is because we are selling you the best shit we can
find.
Uh,
the shit that we use,
everything we sell,
we use.
Um,
I use all of the strength and conditioning equipment.
I use all the supplements and I talked too much on a.com.
Oh and it used the codeword Rogan save yourself 10% of any and all supplements.
And in the higher primates shirts,
they're all in stock there.
Um,
I know I'm fucking real slow at getting them bitches going,
but uh,
they're all in stock now and some new ones coming.
That's a higher primate.com.
Boom.
Tommy Buns is here.
Woo.
Okay,
well good
Joe Rogan podcast.
Nick Diaz doesn't fight in the UFC or it hasn't fought in the UFC for a long
time.
That that soundbite is even cooler.
Yeah,
it is.
It's like so lucky moment in time.
Hilarious.
Yeah.
This,
uh,
this weekend Tommy buns and I were in New York having a good time in the big
apple.
That was fun,
man.
It was fun.
It was a good time to show is insane.
They were the nicest fucking people on the planet earth.
It's so nice.
Yeah.
He's,
you don't always look at when you started talking about sizeable crowds when you
started talking about over a thousand people.
Yeah.
But for them to be that nice felt like a room of,
what was it that,
you know,
it was kind of a screwy situation.
Excuse me.
Because,
um,
we,
uh,
we're at this old venue and this place,
the only way you could get to the floor where
the auditorium is,
is you had to take an elevator and add the bank of four elevators.
Two of them were broken and don't forget the building had thousands of people in
it for other massive events to massive events.
The stern show party,
like birthday bash,
birthday bash,
that was on the fungus.
Yeah.
He was on one floor and there was,
what was that other,
there was another fee.
Hawks Superbowl party was on.
Exactly.
Yeah.
There's a Seahawks part houses thousands of people.
And then our show was sold out for months.
So it was like,
it was madness and it was all these people having to go from floor to floor on
elevators.
It's so weird.
The two like to um,
to do a room that big that is not a ground floor room,
10th floor and 10th floor.
It's oldest shit theater.
The places oldest shit,
it's really fucking cool.
Building is bad ass.
It's like there's a lot of those old buildings in New York City that are like,
you feel it if you feel different when you're in them.
Yeah.
Cause you know,
like when was this building made 1909.
Whoa.
And you're walking around it and first of all there's solid as fuck.
You know,
think about a building that's been there for a hundred fucking years and it's
still rock solid.
I mean they made some goddamn buildings back then.
But,
uh,
on top of that,
it's just got all this history in it.
You know,
these,
all these people have been through it and it had some strange design,
I guess a flaw or I don't know what you would say,
but just a byproduct of the design.
There was a wind whistling through the entire hotel,
the entire,
it was not a hotel.
The entire convention said,
whatever you call it,
Manhattan Center.
Yeah.
The entire place.
Like a 30 mile an hour wind.
Like you would open doors and when would comment,
but it was warm.
You couldn't find the source of the,
you couldn't be like,
oh,
this windows open.
That's where the wins from.
It was some sort of an effect of all these doors being open and the wind coming
in from the front door.
So the wind would come in from the front door with such momentum that it would
go down these hallways and literally make it upstairs.
So you'd be on the 10th floor and the wind would come whistling through,
I mean,
strong wind.
And the weird thing is that like to get to our,
to the room,
to bike to backstage,
you go up,
you know you go up to the 10th floor and you go down like eight hallways with
turns.
So you feel like you're in this weird labyrinth.
You know,
there's not like you go,
well this is open.
It's right here.
That's where winds coming from you.
We've all the way into this area.
And then the wind is hitting you from every angle and it's warm.
It's not even cold wind cause it's freezing outside.
But by the time the wind gets to you,
it's been heated up by the building.
So we've got let's like some sort of an intern,
internal baby tornado thing going on.
It was a,
yeah.
You know how tornadoes,
I think part of what causes tornadoes in some hurricanes is the two different
heats colliding with each other.
Like a warm water and cold air or yeah,
I did that.
And warm.
Yeah.
There's something about,
you know,
weather fronts and conditions colliding and wonder if that has any factor.
And the cold air becoming,
you know,
like whipping around that building like that and,
and becoming warm.
Even when we went into the green room,
um,
we felt the,
you know,
the,
that wind.
Yeah.
And I was like,
Oh I moved,
cause there's a curtain there,
you move the curtain and there's no window.
I thought window was open.
It was so I just didn't know where it was confusing like where it was coming
from.
It's how's it hitting us right now?
Yeah,
it's really weird.
And you know,
when you think about like wind and buildings,
like I think about things like,
like remember that movie backdraft Oh yeah.
And then like that was like the first open doors that when you are in a fire,
the,
when you open windows and you open doors affects the amount of oxygen coming to
the fire.
And sometimes it's almost like an explosion like comes at you and all this wind
in air and heat and temperature that those are the,
we,
we deal with them so often.
Like on a stable basis.
Air conditioned rooms,
like especially in California,
pretty stagnant climates,
pretty static climate.
But when things change like radically and have these weird effects,
like you realize like how bizarre the whole idea really is in the first place.
Yeah.
Air is invisible air around us all the time.
Whipping,
being around and moving and you could feel it when it blows on it.
If you don't see shit you don't see shit.
It's also like one of the basic kind of building blocks of the world of life.
And I think most people know very little like me about it.
Like you kind of go like,
how do I not know more about how that works?
And I don't,
I'm just like,
yeah,
no oxygen feeds fire.
And that's like kind of my extent of my knowledge about it.
It would be weird if Manhattan put a big fucking wall around it.
That would be the way to avoid the,
the uh,
the window.
That would certainly,
yeah,
just put a huge wall.
The top of the buildings would still be wiggling probably.
Yeah.
Well,
the engineer that in them,
the fact that they can sway,
right?
Yeah.
I mean all new buildings will definitely like buildings in the last 20 years.
All Wa like sway,
especially if they're built well,
I'm sure in New York,
San Francisco,
La,
you know,
they expect them to have a tolerance for earthquakes.
I was in a ray Kurzweil's house in San Francisco.
He's that Google guy.
He works for Google now.
Um,
the guy who will works with the artificial technology and you know,
he's a proponent of the idea of the trends in dental man,
that one day we're going to be able to transcend our biological existence and
either become a part of a computer or download consciousness to computers.
Fascinating.
Fascinating dude.
But he lives on the top of his fucking building,
you know,
and like,
this is San Francisco man.
Like this is a crazy place to live like this.
This fucking thing moves,
man.
Don't you feel weird about those?
A Malibu homes on sticks.
Fuck yeah,
those people are crazy.
Craziest shit.
Remember when we were in New York this weekend when we were flying in,
we flew over areas that hurricane sandy hit in New Jersey and you see like
we're buildings used to be.
You see like these areas where shit is just wiped out.
Yeah.
It's very,
you fucking real scary man.
Like it doesn't happen that often.
No.
But when it does happen,
your fucked and it can happen.
We just,
we're basing everything on such a short timeline.
You know,
our ideas of what,
whether it's possible.
It was only based on the last couple of hundred years.
It's true.
It's basically on a couple years.
And then you also only live so long.
Like can you talk about like history time in history,
you know,
a,
a human lifespan is not even like,
you don't even measure how often something happens by,
so we only have a rep,
we only refer to things happening through like,
oh,
it hasn't happened since.
Like my grandfather was rambling.
It's not that long ago.
Yeah.
That happened fucking yesterday in terms of history.
So yeah,
it happens pretty often actually to put it in perspective,
think about the lifetime of like say a house fly.
What do they live?
They live like seven days,
10 days or something like that out.
Okay,
let's find out.
How long has the house,
I think it's a couple of days thinking about how many horrific things have
happened in like modern recorded history weather wise.
If you,
if you lay that over time over stuff we don't know about like really bad natural
disasters happen all the time.
Seven days.
That's how long it fly lives.
Yeah,
most of them.
Seven days.
Sometimes as long as two months.
Hello,
so two bucks.
I'm old school pen here for a minute.
Just think about how little change happens over the course of seven days in the
world.
I mean sometimes yes,
sometimes no,
but the idea of basing the weather on what happens in seven day increments is
fucking completely ridiculous.
Cause we know about seasons.
We'll seasons don't exist to a God damn fly rod and father's Day and world was
frozen,
things were dark,
life was terrifying.
There was no shit anywhere to lend in.
You know,
my pappy was around last month when the shit would drop,
it would freeze instantly.
We couldn't lay eggs.
You know what I mean?
They,
that's what their version of the world.
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
But then you talked to like 10 generations later.
It's sort of like a game of Thrones type of thing where they're talking about
the winter being months or years instead of months.
I still haven't seen that show.
No take care of you.
I know one of the things about winter is winter is varying lengths in this crazy
world that they live in.
Sometimes winter lasts for years,
for years.
Fuck that.
It's coming and they're all terrified.
At winter,
we're all terrified at winter.
It gives you a good perspective because we know that winter's going to be,
even if it's an Iowa,
even if it's somewhere like Michigan's fucking cold as shit.
It's four months,
you know,
tough it up.
Suck it up.
You'll be all right.
But if winter was 40 years,
you got to move.
I don't want to hear your argument for why you stayed.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
You know,
the,
like the thinking behind that,
it's like that,
that really is what it's like,
the difference between living in Michigan and living in California.
Yeah.
I mean there's,
there's some places where people live that have pretty extensive and sometimes
brutal winters,
nothing compared to 40 years.
But I'm saying there's,
you go further north into Canada.
Yeah.
It was definitely cities that have a,
like you could argue that it's pretty seriously winter by October and then it
gets,
it just gets varying degrees of worse,
you know,
so like,
they're like,
this doesn't winter yet.
I know it's five out,
but wait til next month.
And you're like,
okay.
And then you go into November,
December,
those are freezing.
January,
February of the worst.
And it's still cold in that place in March and sometimes into April.
May.
Yeah.
So you're talking about can go to Edmonton crazy snow storm and Matt and cold as
fuck wrong.
It's cold as fuck.
Yeah.
I ran into a couple in Phoenix that came to the shows or shows down there and
they live in Edmonton and they said they uh,
they take the summer off or the winter off the winner and they just go to
Arizona.
So like fuck this,
fuck this.
Yeah.
Especially Phoenix.
Phoenix is great in the summertime.
Oh my God,
it's crazy.
But in the wear time it's dream.
It's beautiful.
That hundred and 30 degrees in the summertime is fucking retarded though.
It's horrible that,
that in like a,
in Vegas you're like,
what the fuck are we doing?
Yeah.
It gets like one 10 all the time.
We were just out there cooking like a hairdryer in your face.
If you happen to like walk on the pavement.
Oh my God.
Or get into a car and then you're looking at your,
the thing you turned the car on,
it says like one 22 and your dashboard and you're like,
what is happening?
That's the sun.
Yeah.
These people,
they live most of their life in Edmonton.
Then they were like,
fuck that.
We think about it.
Everybody would if they could.
Yeah.
I mean there's no such thing as like,
I really,
you know,
I understand people that like the seasons and all that and you know the change,
but nobody wants to be around 20 below for extensive periods of times.
Usually that's,
that's,
you know,
reasonable.
I think you,
you kind of want to get out of that naturally after a while.
Did you ever see that show a life below zero.
It's one of those Alaska shows.
People are living in these strange climates and there's this woman who operates
this a refueling station and it's I think a hundred and something miles north of
the Arctic circle.
So this crazy leg hurts inside to think of that.
This is a bad ass bitch.
She's by herself up there and uh,
she was attacked by a bear once.
I don't know how she survived,
but it broke her leg and I think maybe her hip to and bid into her head.
That her,
yeah,
that's her.
Cause you have a beard.
She's got a little something going on.
Okay.
You went to if you were old lady.
The more the bath.
Yeah.
Normally she doesn't look like that.
All right.
She doesn't have the frost and fast.
Don't be cruel to me.
I just saw a beard and I was like,
she has my beard.
She's a tough,
broad math and I've been trying to figure this lady out.
I watched the show all the time and I'm trying to figure out this lady out.
I think,
um,
this is what it is.
I think she's a tough lady that enjoys challenges and so like her life is better
for her when it's just this constant struggle against nature and the elements.
She enjoys it.
She seems to like thrive off of it.
I think that's a,
you know,
there's individuals you put you,
you set up circumstances for,
it's better for them.
Like in a big picture.
Like some people work better with structure and some people work better with no
structure,
you know,
and I think you keep progressing along that line.
Some people can thrive in harsher situate,
like this is ideal for some people,
but I think it's not for a lot,
you know,
it's,
there's a minimum amount of people that actually want to be and will thrive in
a,
in a,
an environment like that.
Well everyone is always looking for Phoenix to go to in the middle of the
winter,
everyone is looking for comfort,
right?
And what these people are doing is going the exact opposite way and they're
saying,
we're just looking to make it exciting and struggle every day.
But we choose to do it this way.
Like these are all what you call subsistence hunting people.
Meaning they live completely off the land.
They get their vegetables from the grow on them.
They'd get their fish by chip.
That woman right there,
that uh,
in you went woman,
her fucking whole family has had massive loss because of people falling through
the ice and drowning.
She lost her mother.
I think she lost her brother.
She was lost like several,
like close family members,
members fell through the ice and fucking froze to death.
You know.
I mean,
this is some harsh shit.
Yeah.
This world is crazy and they have to do it.
That's the only way you're going to get fish.
So they're out there on this river that's flowing river,
that freed the top of it freezes and you're standing on it and if you fall
through,
that's a wrap,
son.
It's over.
But there's no other way,
like there's no other way to get the fish out of there,
but she also has,
there's purpose for her being up there.
In other words,
it's a refueling,
like she's there for a service or no,
it's,
she's just there.
No women.
Just,
that's how they live.
That's just how she lives.
That's how they make their money.
They don't,
they don't have jobs.
They just get fish out of the,
uh,
out of the river.
I mean,
this is,
there's several groups of people,
but she's looking at that at that.
Then you went woman and her husband.
Her husband,
yeah.
Yeah.
There's,
there's four or five different,
do they sell fish or just fish to eat?
They self,
some things they do a lot of trading now.
They're like,
they'll trade like give you a half of a Caribou.
I need,
uh,
some fan belts from my car to repair my snowmobile or what have you.
They all,
they'd traveled by snowmobile everywhere,
everywhere.
So when they're outside,
they're outside man,
they're not,
there's no like heated trucks where they're driving around in,
no sir.
No.
[inaudible] a crazy hard life.
But they like it.
They do like it.
There's,
this one lady is really fascinating because she said,
I mean it's hard to tell what someone's really like when you got a camera in
their face.
Yeah.
It's hard to tell who they are if they're relaxed and you just talking to them.
Like sometimes it takes months to get to know someone defined.
You know,
what,
what goes on behind the scenes inside of their head.
So you don't really know that lady that well from watched her on that show.
But what you can tell is it's something that she's enjoying about being up there
and this really scary environment where she's already been attacked by a fucking
bear.
I mean,
Jesus,
she got attacked by,
and those are grizzly bears.
These are the big brown bears.
They're not like black bears that you could scare away.
Like they're,
they're there to fuck you up.
Yeah.
She hunts Caribou and fucking small birds and whatever she's following up there.
That's where she gets her meet.
The bear was like,
I see your beard.
I'll give you a break.
We both had beards.
No.
I think the bear,
she probably shot him or something.
I don't know what the full story like there's not really much topping badass
stories as much as I got attacked by a bear and I fucked like I killed that
bear.
Yeah.
Like what's a better story than that?
Maybe a shark,
but sharks,
the idea of you fighting off a shark,
it gets crazy.
You know how much chance.
But if you did,
if you're like,
you know,
that's why I got this half arm right here.
It's like if a shark kicks your ass on the shore on a shore,
say if you have a giant knife in your hand,
you the keys shark kicks your ass on a shore.
But like a shark deserves it.
Yes.
Because you were just fucking,
well,
how's the shark and get you on the ground.
You can take a great white shark,
put it on the beach.
I will fuck that thing up is no chance I will get behind him.
I'll stab him.
Writing a stupid brain.
Yep.
I'll find it.
A little pea brain.
I'll chop away at the top of his head afterwards and I'm sure he'll open his
jaws and shit would over.
Dude,
you're not in the ocean.
You fucked.
This is my world.
[inaudible] House.
Yeah.
You're not gonna bite me.
I'm going to stick fucking a knife in your brain and then I'm going to eat you.
Yeah.
But if you're in the water and you have about the same amount of chance,
except the only thing that saves you is that sharks are stupid.
So if there's some way that you could do like,
jab it in the nose with like a harpoon.
If you had like one of those fish harpoons,
like dudes to go,
um,
what do they call it?
A spear fishing.
Shoot.
The spheres.
Sure.
Yeah,
the spear guns.
If you could like stab it in the nose with that,
you might be able to get the fuck away from you because you know that they're
kind of sensitive in their nose,
but you might not.
Yeah,
most likely you will.
Probably not.
Most likely you'll miss no bite your arm off and you bleed out,
you know?
Yeah.
They swim pretty fucking fast too.
Unless you can swim like 40 miles an hour,
which I don't think some homeless guy in California yesterday got attacked by a
mountain lion.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
Yeah.
I got to get fucked up.
Homeless Guy.
Was He hiking?
Yeah,
it was outside.
It was like camping,
you know,
talking about mountain mine.
Yeah.
Not good to there,
you know,
unusual homeless activity.
They're going to have more and more that they don't really camp when the hell
knows.
It's more just they're always camping.
Cause the best campus homeless people that are constantly camping.
Well,
it depends on what kind of homeless.
Obviously this guy,
it seems like he might have been a crazy person at long week of being homeless
in the city.
We'd go up to the hills for a little bit.
Yeah,
man,
that ain't fun man.
That sucks.
It's going to happen more.
You know,
this is something we talked about on the opiate Anthony show when we were in New
York.
Talked about a mountain lion attacks and yeah,
man and a here.
There's a group of people right there.
Yeah.
That was a guy in the back loans.
Uh,
Ricky Gervais',
Jim Norton and Opie and Anthony and,
and us.
What a fun room man.
Fuck you.
I was a lot of fun.
It was a good time.
It's so cool meeting.
I'm a big fan of Ricky Gervais'.
Nice Guy,
man.
Super Nice Guy.
Nice guy.
Really easy to talk to.
Very interesting wolf fact that you learned also about jaw.
The biting.
Yeah.
They have a bite that's like five times more powerful than a pitbull.
I can hear that.
Yeah.
I couldn't believe that either.
Man.
Definitely thought that he was making that up or exaggerating it.
Well,
you know,
sometimes it's,
it's sometimes it's like someone tells you something,
it's just not correct and you repeat it.
I've done that before of course.
And sometimes you know,
you,
you're not even intending to mislead you.
You heard something or you,
you think you remember the number and you're like,
I think it's this number and you just throw it out.
I've done that.
I thought it was going to be bigger.
Obviously I think a wolf bites harder.
Yeah.
But I didn't think it was going to be five times fucking bananas.
It snap.
They can snap the leg bone of an elk.
That's insane.
What a crazy,
you know the idea that people think that's a dog that's so silly.
And now when you think about like just that you right,
whatever you already knew about them,
you think about that added stat and you think about the fact that they hunt in
packs.
I think about three or four of those mouths with those at what that's possible
of doing in how quick amount of time,
you know,
I mean like those,
they ambush you.
Yeah.
You know,
they come this way that way and pretty soon you're looking around like,
oh shit.
And that's what happens to the animals,
you know,
they get,
they get trapped.
It's so funny.
Steve Rinella,
my friend,
hunter guy from the show meter was talking about there was this,
um,
uh,
one thing,
were where people were talking about running a and trying to keep up with wolves
and like,
I could a man tried to keep up with a wolf,
right?
And one of the ways that they tested it is they took these wolf dogs and they
let these wolf dogs go.
And then they had these people run through the mountains and like see if they
can keep up with the wolf dog.
Like,
you know,
see,
uh,
like wolves can run faster,
but sometimes people can run longer instead of your base.
Well,
it,
the wolves,
dogs,
Wolf dogs are not wolves.
And he was like,
the way he described it as like,
that's like taking an alien in,
an alien comes down and finds the fattest,
most add a shape guy with the worst diet and says,
run as fast as you can.
We want to see how fast humans can run.
Oh,
really?
That's the equivalent of that.
Isn't that a good,
yeah.
Isn't that a great analogy?
Because he gives a wolf is a wolf these up.
They're not dogs and not getting fed.
They're out there running down elk and biting their legs in half.
Right.
And this is not a wolf dog.
They're fucking Wolfe's.
Did you watch this past season of eastbound and down when he gets a,
he gets his kid a wolf,
see that or no?
No,
no he didn't.
It's so ridiculous.
You see that Brian?
Like he um,
uh,
what's his name?
Mcbride.
Kenny powers gets his kids a pet wolf
and like it just keeps it in the garage and he's like Jesus Christ.
And it's not like a big chain,
like a big,
like a chain fence is keeping it.
Oh my hat.
And it's just like salad and like I was growling at the kids and he was like,
go feed it and they like have to throw meat at the,
at the wolf.
So that's a great show.
Yeah.
So I mean this is,
that's what he got.
So ridiculous.
It seems legit debate.
It was a perfect gift for Toby.
My new high pay and television.
Y'All.
I'm not going to be around the house as much as I'd like to be.
So it's very important that Toby has a strong male role models.
The Spirit God
spirit count
cause this opportunity off family's going to be taken care of forever.
Who knows?
Next stop to space camp.
It was so funny.
Funny.
It's such a good show.
That dude is Goddamn hilarious.
Hysterical.
Did you see him?
And this is the end.
Yes.
Holy Shit.
Is he good?
I mean that movie I ran into a um,
uh,
what the fuck's his name?
Craig Robinson the other night at the,
at the Improv.
Who's in it where I was telling him I go,
dude,
that movie is so God damn funny.
And you were so funny in it,
you know,
and uh,
we were talking about Kenny power scene.
Like when he comes in,
when he,
I mean like the movies outstanding and then he comes in and it just,
the whole thing goes through this whole whole new level of craziness.
He's hilarious.
This guy,
I love that character.
Any powers of really cocky,
fucking complete idiot character,
but just subtle enough of an idiot that like that kind of shit.
And I'm not going to be around a lot more than he has a strong role model.
It doesn't grow up to be a pansy.
He's,
he's such a buffoon.
So fucking funny.
Those guy characters are really funny man.
You're the best part about that character.
I read interviews with him and like the other guys,
the uh,
the Jody hill,
I think Admin,
Ben,
I can't remember his name,
but they're like,
all are behind this.
And they're saying like,
how,
you know,
a lot of people appreciate the character and think it's funny for what it is.
And then some people are big fans on another level where they're like,
yeah,
he's right,
like came powers is,
that's how I think too.
Like they're that kind of fan where they're like,
fuck yeah man.
That's exactly how I am.
And that's,
we're fucking Americans who we are tired of this bullshit getting a wolf from my
kid too.
Fucking bad ass shit,
Kenny.
Yeah,
it's annoying if that dude's,
you're fucking neighbor.
But on TV,
they're awesome.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Fucking phenomenal.
It's,
but it's almost better than a reality show because of a reality show.
Like if you had a guy like Kenny powers to game reality show,
he would become famous and he would get annoying.
Like essentially that's what you got with the duck dynasty people.
You've got a reality show where,
oh,
whoops,
you made someone famous.
He's a fucking idiot and a homophobe and he will,
I don't get it.
Why would a man choose a man's?
And they're not choosing dummy,
you know?
But now this guys on TV,
he's famous and then you look on Facebook and you've got these knuckle heads
with their fucking,
what about freedom of speech support?
Duck dynasty in the fort,
the Ma,
whatever memory is first amendment.
Then she didn't read the constitution.
Shut your hole.
And that's shown.
I'm amazed.
I mean I get that like stupid as fuck.
The fact that like that there,
you know,
you're following this family and you feel like this is how they really are.
It's all set up.
Like the show is like way over produced.
So obvious guys,
AVN even that was creepy.
They're just hanging out at AVN like they have,
they have tech dynasty guys.
Duck beards.
Yeah.
It was really weird.
And ABN warrants two words.
They were there like the weekend.
Why would they there?
Cause they,
that's the cool thing to do if you were the duck dynasty.
So they were there for the whole weekend doing press or no,
they were just hanging out and they were at porn event.
So they're normal.
They're like watching people fuck good for them.
You know that,
but just not men's.
And Jesus is essentially like a Kenny powers in real life.
That's the problem with them in real life point.
So it's like having a guy like this in,
in the TV show eastbound and down.
It's actually even better because it's so good.
It's better than a reality show.
A reality show.
You'd be making that asshole famous.
Right.
And there'd be people on Facebook.
I fucking agree with a man.
Yeah.
I'll support them.
Fucking support in the shit out of him and his right as an American.
Yeah.
You know these,
these ideas that,
what is this?
He says,
will feral and Kenny powers and welfare owns a cardiac dealership.
It's like that.
It's the best fucking shit ever.
Is this a from eastbound down?
I need to watch that whole season,
man.
I really do.
But um,
yeah,
there's a lot of those people in real life and sometimes folks,
all they need is like one example like that.
And that'll little shift.
Like you could have people on the fence who are just thinking about like waking
up and going,
you know,
what do I care if someone's gay man?
What?
What is it in me that gets mad about these gates people and why?
Why?
Why do I,
you know,
say they're going to burn in hell.
Maybe I should just fucking relax.
And then they see that guy on TV and they see he's been kicked off TV.
You know what that Shit I'll fucking headed up to here with these queers,
Mike.
There's a tipping point where a guy like that I'm a television show and that,
that whole debate getting out there without any real rational response from
either the media,
from a and e from anybody.
No,
no one liked gets on TV and says,
look,
we're here to make a big statement about this.
This is what's wrong with this and this is why we have a problem with it,
okay?
It's not about freedom of speech.
It's not about speaking your mind.
It's about what's on your mind,
man,
right?
What is on your mind,
your mind,
your mind is that they're going to burn in hell.
You're your mind is some fire and brimstone.
If someone is in love with another man and marries him,
you're an idiot,
okay?
You're a dangerous idiot.
You,
you,
you're taking people that I know for a fact are born that way.
I'm no scientist,
but I know a gay kid in my neighborhood.
He's five [inaudible].
He's fucking
gay,
okay?
There's nothing wrong with that,
but he's gay.
This kid's gay.
His parents were trying to get him to play football.
He doesn't want to have nothing to do with football.
He's always dressing up in dresses.
He puts girls clothes on.
He plays with dolls.
He's a gay kid,
okay?
He,
he,
he likes boys.
It's the weirdest thing to see from the jump,
but his parents were very supportive,
you know what I mean?
They,
they wanted them to try boy things.
He's not really into it,
but there's no hate going on,
so he's going to be okay.
Devin tried beating Madigan yet.
No,
but what,
what happens if a kid like that is watching television and he realizes that he's
gay and you know,
maybe he's 12 or 13 he just thinking about sex and he's watching this and he
feels horrible about himself,
which he probably does.
Cause that definitely happened.
You know?
Right over nothing or something he can't control over something he's born with.
That's why it's dangerous.
It's just as dangerous as being critical about people for a bunch of other
things they can't control.
It's just as dangerous as being racist.
People don't understand that.
They don't see it that way.
But a person,
I don't know why anybody would want to choose.
I hang out with a black man over hanging out with a white man.
Yeah.
I mean I just don't get it.
There's more there.
That's the same statement.
It's the same statement really is.
There's no difference,
man.
That's the parallel
when people talk about like,
Oh,
you know,
you're not the same thing you've been through and are like comparing the civil
rights movement to this,
but like what you're,
the thing that's similar is that you're just,
you're trying to put down and isolate a group of people for something that they
can't control because you don't want any part of that.
So that's the parallel is that,
you know,
whether it's a,
you don't want to hang around or are you want to put down black people or Asian
people or whoever it may be.
That's the same thing as putting down somebody and not wanting them to have the
rights just because they were born with a certain sexual orientation.
That's the parallel.
Well,
people don't want anyone to make the comparisons to civil rights.
They don't want anyone to be able to cause then they're like,
oh,
we really are wrong.
Well,
no,
because,
because what I'm saying is people like civil rights,
people don't like it because they feel that it's somehow or another diminishes
the,
the horrors of slavery.
Right?
Like there's an issue that people have with like comparing something to racism,
you know,
and black people in particular have an issue with gay people comparing
themselves and the plight of Gay Americans to racism.
They,
I've seen it,
I've heard people like scream and yell about it,
about it's not the same and fuck you and you know,
and then,
yeah.
And Gay,
some people gay is a choice.
I've seen a lot of weirdness almost as if they're worried that it somehow or
another diminishes what's horrible about slavery,
which is ridiculous.
Slavery was horrible.
Still is.
Racism was horrible.
Still is,
but so's homophobia.
That's just as horrible.
Yeah.
Like the people that think it's not,
it's just because you're not gay.
It's that simple.
If that was who you are and people were angry about who you are,
it would be just as bad as you being born Chinese and people hate Chinese people
and you're like,
what the fuck?
Man,
I didn't do anything.
You hate me because of the way I was.
Yeah.
It's the
same goddamn thing,
you know.
And the idea is Whoa,
yeah,
well nobody ever owned gay people,
but they killed them.
It's in the Bible.
It's in the Bible that you should be put to death for lying with another man.
You don't think that they'd been persecuted.
It's,
it's,
there's a hundred different religions where it's illegal or against their rules
to be gay.
Yeah.
You could start with being with Islam and work your way up through a bunch of
other different,
well there's,
there's countries that don't even again in fucking Russia.
Russia's that's insane that Russia is a,
did you see for these discriminatory laws against gay people?
They do.
And they,
um,
the Putin came out cause we were about to have the winter Olympics there and
said that like gay athletes have nothing to worry about.
Like they're not going to be discriminated against when they're in the,
in Russia for the Winter Olympics.
But,
um,
you know,
like rules still apply where like you're,
you're the,
you're not supposed to be talking about it to anybody and giving your opinions
on,
so like,
we're not going to do anything to you because you're getting,
you're here,
but don't be talking about it.
Yeah.
And stay away from kids and stay away from kids,
which was the most,
yeah,
that was the crime.
That's the part that I feel that's how big,
whoa.
Big.
Whoa.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
they are fostering an environment of hate and fear and we should look at that
very carefully as,
as people that understand human nature.
Okay.
Let's look at what you would want if you were trying to dominate a nation and
control it in a sort of a dictatorship perform,
which is essentially what Putin's got going on there.
Yeah.
Call Him.
He say he was voted in,
or what if the guy's not going anywhere for you get voted out,
you know?
I mean,
he left his term,
put in someone who worked for him and then took over again after that guy has
gotten me,
he's running Russia.
Yeah,
definitely.
The way to run,
the way to be a dictator and the way to run an empire.
It's through fear to control and fear.
And as many enemies as you have that you have to protect the people from the
better.
And so one of the things that dictators do is they start pushing people against
other people.
If you can get people to be inter conflicted amongst the ranks of the normal
civilians,
you can guarantee that they're going to be busy,
they're going to have conflict,
they're not going to be able to deal with taxes or the rules or the military
choices the military is making.
They're so busy with their own shit worried about these people going after this
group and this ethnic group going after that group and you know,
the gays were going to touch their kids.
I mean there's,
and then,
you know,
fostering violence against gay people is going to foster anger from gay people
and straight people.
I mean,
there's a blowback on both sides and they get you guarantee conflict.
It's so,
it's so,
uh,
your guarantees is that kind of like,
it's so crazy outrageous to,
you know,
suggest or imply that gays will want children,
like the idea that someone is trolling.
Yeah.
Like the idea that they're not,
uh,
you know,
adults with natural,
sexual just happens
to be through a different group,
but that they would be not be able to control themselves and be attracted to it.
So,
so crazy.
It's so crazy and so stupid.
I think a thing by the way about like,
why you,
uh,
you say black people sometimes get 'em more fired up about the comparison is in
my experience,
a lot of,
uh,
black people that come from like really Christian homes,
view of their,
their Mo more intolerant towards gay people.
A lot of times the ones who come from really Christian homes.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
There's a lot of that.
Well,
that's what happened with proposition eight in California.
I mean,
that was a real embarrassment where they repealed gay people's right to,
to,
to marry,
and those was an embarrassment and a disproportionate amount of black people
voted for that.
Yeah.
It was a weird number.
It was like over 50%.
But I think even like outside of the Christian homes,
you would find a,
I think in a lot,
a lot of cases,
a more,
uh,
homophobia in the black community.
I think it exists more.
That's so weird.
Yeah,
I do.
I think it does.
How much black worker you've done.
I'm done very,
I can dance,
I can do a lot of things.
Um,
I'm saying that like,
you know what,
I get black people are 13% of our population.
And what I'm,
all I'm saying is that I think a bigger percentage of the population is home.
I'm getting it from just having spoken and been exposed to a lot of,
uh,
black people.
What's amazing,
apparently a lot of these,
uh,
African American churches were,
they're the organized drives to vote against proposition eight.
But it was upsetting that like the,
the,
the church community is bigger in black culture.
Like going to the,
that's a bigger thing.
And I think that,
that they're pretty openly most of the time saying that it's bad that you know,
gays are bad.
So I think that that kind of breeds that homophobia more in that community.
I'm not saying that all black people are homophobic or that they're all
preaching that and all doing that.
I'm saying that I think that exists more in that culture,
in that community.
That's interesting.
Um,
there's a,
there's not just that,
but Mormons also spent a lot of money.
Mormons very much.
I mean,
I think a lot of people who have given the credit to the Mormons for defeating
that eight,
right?
Yeah.
Well they put a lot of money until recently.
Which is,
I had a joke about it and,
uh,
talking monkey's in space.
Oh yeah.
About,
about,
um,
the Mormon should be afraid of gay people because if you sell him enough to be a
Mormon,
yeah.
That was really nice.
Someone could talk to you to be in the Mormon and they can talk you into soccer
their day.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's just a matter of how much time they spend with you and then you break down
the whole hit.
You know,
what Mormonism is like,
which is like,
right,
isn't it?
The guy was like,
no,
I got
all the rules they gave him to me.
But you know what's interesting is that this,
um,
this also becomes another point of contention because now,
now black people are being persecuted by gay people,
right?
I mean it puts this weird thing,
it's not another battle taking place.
I don't believe in those kinds of conspiracies necessarily that like the whole
social structure of this country's organized keep people poor.
So there's conflict and key people rich.
So they keep voting for corporations and they want to protect their wealth.
And this is and keep the,
the,
the divide between the two and every now and then,
you know,
organized chaos in a way that we were sort of kind of hinting that maybe Putin
or someone does.
But if you're going to do it,
this is the way to do it.
The way to do it is to take like what's you ordinarily like liberals,
okay,
let's let's break down liberals.
Liberals like left wing,
they are almost always voting pro minority.
They vote pro minority and almost always pro gay rights.
So what better to separate that mess.
And,
and,
and cause confusion amongst the ranks.
It's to get those two factors on your enemy,
these two like static constant factors and have them Duke it out,
right?
So now you have people who support gay rights and people that support,
you know,
the,
the idea that gay should be married duking it out with,
with black people,
with minorities and Christian minorities who almost universally vote democratic.
So it's like Whoa,
you would,
that's a tricky thing you did there.
Oh right.
Cause by causing trouble between those groups of people,
you essentially weekend the entire Party.
And that's what happens if you,
if you connect black people and gay people that black people keep gay people
from voting,
the whole left wing becomes a fucking mess.
Right?
Comes cap because white guilt runs rampant through,
through the left,
like through like Democrats.
Like there's so many,
especially educated Democrats who are filled with white guilt and they don't
want to come down on black people and they don't want to come down on black
people.
Even for something as heinous as proposition eight,
proposition eight was being supported by a bunch of church going white people,
much more like if it was being read,
you know,
strictly by Baptist but white baptists and there was all these white baptist
leaders on TV talk.
You would marginalize them as fools is buffoons they would joke about them,
but people weren't doing that about black people.
It was this weird sort of like touchy subject.
Tough to do.
You know,
you didn't see people mocking all these black people like it,
whether it's on the daily show or whether it's on any of these left wing
websites weren't mocking black people for,
for the majority of them voting for this.
Right?
Yeah.
You didn't,
you didn't see that.
No.
It's,
it's true.
The whole,
the whole thing.
It gets very tricky.
Yeah.
There's,
um,
it's interesting to like,
uh,
you know,
the big thing now is for the last few years,
people trying to figure out,
you know,
how the Republican party can,
um,
really compete again
when the,
uh,
when the White House and when certain other elections in,
one of the things that keeps being brought up is that the younger,
there's,
there's certain like,
um,
constants right among the left and the right,
like if you go abortion,
like,
you know,
he's pro life was approached with and when with the,
the gay thing is that the far right won't let you know,
support that,
right.
They're not going to support it.
But the younger generation of new voters,
even ones who are conservative,
have conservative values,
grew up in a world where it's more like welcoming to the gay community and,
and they're,
they're not necessarily like moderate ones can be.
I tell you,
you're always going to try to win over,
right.
Somebody who can kind of not an extremist,
they're leaning left now younger voters because of some of these extreme
constants.
And so it's like if the,
if that party,
the right could embrace something like that,
would that even the playing field for them?
I think if most certainly.
Yeah.
And would they then be able to compete more for these maybe younger voters that
you know,
the more open minded young people who feel like that's a basic,
right.
It's kind of an interesting way to look at it.
Like if you change your position on that,
do you then get somebody who you want elected,
you'll get a lot of the no nonsense people that just happened to vote left
because of social issues.
Right.
You would get those and that's,
that's a pretty substantial number.
70% of black people voted in favor for proposition eight.
70% of people of black people voted that gay people shouldn't be allowed to be
married and that they should take that right away from them.
That's incredible.
That's fucking gross.
That's gross and terrifying.
It's funny cause I'm reading an article on Huffington Post,
stop blaming California's black voters for proposition eight.
That's what it says.
Yeah.
Okay.
Don't blame them because it's,
a lot of other people voted for it as well.
But if you don't think that it's embarrassing and gross,
that 70% of black people voted for some silly law that takes away the right for
people that are in love to get married.
I think maybe it is,
because if,
I mean obviously it's religious,
that's the big thing.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's the big thing.
Maybe it's like black dudes just don't want to get married at all.
They were like,
man,
fuck this.
No one's getting married.
Let's stop it with the gay people.
If I have less of them get married,
unless the US have to get married.
And I got the black agenda.
Marriage man,
tired of divorce.
I don't know.
It's uh,
it's just,
it's just how people are raised.
I think all of those.
Yeah.
And I mean that's,
people change later on in life.
You know,
you're young,
you think a certain way.
And then if,
uh,
you know,
some of those people will be converted to thinking differently with time,
but you know,
anybody,
you can have your own ideas in this life.
You can have your own thoughts and you can have your own unique point of view.
The real problem is when your ideas start fucking with other people's
lives for no reason.
When your ideas are based on just some shit that you believe that's 2000 plus
years old,
that notebook,
if you want to believe like the gay thing in the Bible,
man,
you're really cherry picking because there's a lot of other shit in there too.
Along with gay people,
like you're not supposed to wear two different types of clothes,
like you're not supposed to wear like silk and cotton.
That's like punishable by,
you know,
it was sins upon your life or smash your hand with the rocks.
I mean there's some,
some great old sayings that they uh,
used to say,
but one of them is like,
you threatened with death if you rent your clothes,
if you tear your clothes.
So like people who have like holes where their needs are and shit like that.
Fashion in the Bible,
you're supposed to die for that.
He's supposed to be put to death for that.
You know,
there's some neighborhoods we could really wipe out,
right?
Go in there and clean house.
They're gone.
Silver Lake.
Yeah.
Several.
Craig doesn't do that anymore.
Or they have a new fashion.
Yeah,
there are cardigans now,
right?
Oh Shit.
Maybe they like all hipsters.
Here's 19 things the Bible for forbids,
uh,
other than homosexuality.
I put this on Twitter the other day cause it's just,
it's so fucking silly.
Here's the exact quote in Leviticus.
Uncover not your heads.
Neither render your closed yet he die.
And lest wrath come upon all the people.
Okay?
So if you,
if you don't uncovered not your head's,
which means don't uncover your head,
keep your head covered.
Got It.
Okay.
If you don't keep your head covered,
that means you're going to die.
And wrath will come upon all the people.
So everyone not wearing a hat,
you fucked us up.
Magic.
If that was the key that all we had to do was all wear hats and God was like,
good,
good.
Peace on earth.
Love hats.
I wrote that shit down a long time ago.
You motherfuckers didn't lizard.
Everyone's caught up in this gay shit.
I want hats.
I want fucking everyone wearing a hat.
Wear a hat by God.
God's orders are where?
Kangols I got stock in that company.
It's like God's hair net.
Like if you work at the restaurant,
you have to wear a hair net.
I don't want to see.
Yes.
God's like you don't wear enhance.
You fuck.
Make a soup over here,
man.
Make no mistake,
folks.
I'm not.
This is how I'm paraphrasing.
I'm directly quoting this from the English translation of the Bible.
Uncover not your heads.
Jesus.
Maybe it meant your their head.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Maybe keeps your Dick covered,
but they didn't call that a head back then.
They called it a mushroom cap.
They thought it was a mushroom.
Yeah.
You're not supposed to trim your beard by the way.
Neither shout out mar the corners of thy beard.
Oh,
how come they're not going crazy about that
is clearly shaving his beard test will come upon us.
It's not convenient.
So fucking stupid.
You know what's even more stupid?
Really religious people with religious tattoos because that's in the Bible.
Do fuck face.
You're not supposed to get tattoos.
You shall not make any cuttings in your flesh for the dead nor
print any marks upon you.
I am the Lord cuts in your flesh for the dead.
Like instead of like,
like marking,
like you have a picture of your mom like Eddie Bravo has got a Kat von d did a
tattoo of his grandma on his chest.
It's beautiful.
It reminds him of his grandma against the Bible death.
Yeah,
man,
you're not supposed to.
I mean,
that's essentially what it is.
Your print something on you.
So if we tend to follow it,
all the rules of the Bible,
it would just be like a murderous rampage constantly.
We would be so lottery,
everyone would be fucked.
Well,
how about every Catholic would go,
would burn at the stake.
Okay.
You would all die in hell because you're not supposed to drink wine in church,
right?
You're not.
You're not supposed to do that.
Let's says in the Bible.
Leviticus ten nine do not drink wine nor strong drink.
Though it was a weird nor thy sons were with the,
when you go into the Tabernacle of the congregation,
lest ye die.
Okay?
So what that means is that you drink wine in church die.
But everybody drinks wine in church,
part of the holy sacraments there.
Even a quote that he said like,
I don't even want you to make a church.
I'd rather,
yes,
well that was Jesus.
See the Jesus stuff is very much different.
The Jesus stuff you gotta get your piss on the Jesus stuff is very different
because Jesus and most of like what a lot of people quote about that is all from
the New Testament and the new testament is even sketchier than the old
testament.
The Old Testament is sketchy because it was originally written in ancient Hebrew
and the oldest versions of some of these stories are actually the Dead Sea
Scrolls,
which are written in Aramaic.
And they're actually on animal skins that they found an area of Israel called
Qumran.
And they found these clay pots and inside these clay pots,
they found these ancient ancient scrolls.
And some of them are so fucked up that they have to piece them together with
like tweezers and they have to,
and they've spent years and years and years and years to ciphering these things,
man.
And you know,
you can see them online.
Actually,
they have photos.
Let me see.
I think there's a website.
Dead Sea Scrolls online,
but that's the only version of the Bible that's in Aramaic.
Yeah.
Dead Sea Scrolls online.
It's actually D,
s s.
Um,
the website is d e s s.
Dot.
collections.img.org.
Just look up Dead Sea Scrolls online and new address.
Yeah,
the Chits we're doing well,
it's some academic,
but you can read these scrolls,
like click on each one,
Brian,
and you can actually get an image of the actual scroll itself.
And,
uh,
all that stuff's on animal skins.
So this is an Aramaic,
which is the only version of the Bible I think that they know of.
That's in Aramaic.
So all this shit that we're,
uh,
we're reading here is the stuff that's from,
essentially the oldest stories of the Bible.
The New Testament was actually commissioned by Constantine.
There's like Roman Emperor Constantine,
big chunks missing from,
it's like,
so there,
it could be like a word that says don't instead of do it.
You know what I mean?
Like,
well it's,
it's,
it's clearly,
you know,
they don't have the full work,
but it's pretty amazing that they even have that because you know,
this is thousands and thousands and thousands of years old and it's made out of
an animal skin.
I mean,
it's really pretty incredible that it exists at all.
even if it's only pieces of it,
but it's so cool that they found that shit in clay pots.
And these of course were stories that were told in like an oral tradition for a
thousand years before anybody figured out how to write them down.
But then you're dealing with the new testament,
which was Constantine and a bunch of bishops put together.
So it's much more recent and they actually know who the people were who put it
together.
And it was all like way after Jesus was dead.
Isn't that crazy though?
When you think about like when you really stop and think about the fact that
like some dudes putting this,
wrote this down and not just some dudes,
but an emperor who clearly wanted to convert all of his people to Christianity
to control them,
but that we still are like,
well this is this thing we got to follow up.
Well,
the Dude Constantine didn't even get baptized until like right before he died.
Like,
you know,
I mean,
I think,
you know,
he had to get baptized so that the next people could say,
no,
we,
we got him.
He's good.
You know,
stay Christian.
Everyone stays Christian.
Cause if he dies and he's not baptized,
you have to admit to the entire world that this guy,
you know,
somehow or another is going to hell.
The guy who converted everybody to Christianity ran the runway,
Roman Empire that way.
And yeah,
hired all these bishops to put together the Bible.
That's where the new test of it comes from.
So when you're dealing with the new testament you're dealing with and even
squirrely or piece of work because it's like the what?
Dubious fucking origins.
Like you're telling me,
Constantine's got a direct line to God,
some murderous Roman Empire guy.
He's got a direct line to God,
bitch,
can I just get the fuck Outta here?
The oldest oldest shit is ridiculous.
The newer,
older shit is ridiculous.
Yeah.
If there was no bible at all,
man,
somebody would try to make one up.
Of course,
some,
some do.
It would be a right now.
Right?
You ever think about,
you know how every year or a few years of a story will come about where a guy's
like,
I'm Christ like Jesus Christ,
I'm bad.
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
whatever,
he'll fucking die in a shoot out or some shit or get arrested.
Uh,
do you ever think about the fact that like 2000 years ago somebody had been
like,
I am God and that that's that guy.
It's just that happened long ago and nothing happened to him.
Of course if you just,
if you're just really good at it,
you could dominate a huge group of people and by the way,
you could also have some really cool shit to say as well as being a fucking nut.
You know,
like Depok show,
Bruh.
Like Depok shopper.
We were talking about him on Ona.
Yeah.
He's got some really cool shit to say.
He's a silly man.
He says a lot of silly shit like,
ah.
I used to be an atheist until I realized I was God.
That was one of his quotes because we're all God.
It's not that kind of what the fuck ever shut up.
You're not God.
You know,
it turns the water into wine,
but Joe didn't do it.
You shut your mouth and we're all God.
Yeah,
I get it.
That's silly.
Shut your mouth.
Don't say shit like that.
It's stupid.
It makes people marginalize.
You marginalizes the whole idea of universal consciousness when you talk and
such fucking vague and silly terms.
Joseph,
oh,
we're all God.
Oh,
please go on.
Go on with your Gucci Sunglasses theory.
You are God though,
if that was true.
Well as simulation theory.
No,
you're a part of a program.
Um,
and you are,
you're running this program somehow or another in the background.
That's the simulation theory is not that you're,
you were ticking off the secret more.
You're thinking instead of simulation theory.
You think that of the power of suggestion or the power of positive thinking or
the idea,
I was thinking of me somewhere in the future that I sitting there watching
myself sleep or you know,
like I,
I'm the one that started the program and I'm kind of playing a game right now.
If my of me right here,
you know what I mean?
Think anybody thinks that I think that,
that you created this whole thing.
I think that's somewhere in the future.
I'm sitting here doing a simulation of myself.
Well,
I don't think people think that they created it.
I think most people think that it's just something that's running that you're a
part of.
Right?
But if you think that you actually created itself,
you know,
why don't you know how to create anything now?
Like how can we not like a computer programmer?
You lost all that knowledge in the simulation?
No.
Cause this me is just a program.
So the you,
it's like you can marginalize yourself and your computer program.
So it can be like some super genius who knows all and say I am going to give
myself limited knowledge and information and there's lots of good realistic
simulation as a,
as a goof to make life more difficult.
I'm going to make myself really dumb and lazy and I'm gonna give myself a club
foot and I'm going to give myself a one hand that works.
In other hand it's like semi paralyzed from birth.
Like it's so crazy like that.
We're all doing it.
We're all creating our own universe and just some people that are really shitty
job of designing themselves now that's just to make it look realistic.
You have to have like leg people around there.
Okay,
so they're not you so they're not real.
That's Melissa Etheridge type thing.
Is that what she,
Melissa Etheridge says that she gets on an airplane.
She's a really happy for all the other people on the airplane because she knows
that an airplane not gonna Crash.
Cause she's on it cause she's a sort of creating her world.
That's awesome.
The power of suggestion.
Really,
really proud of her.
What about,
well maybe she's right.
You know,
here's,
here's the thing.
It's so,
it's so easy to goof on her or anybody who thinks that way,
but we can't prove that that's not the case.
You can't,
we can't,
we can't prove what,
uh,
what kind of power your consciousness has over the world itself.
We assume there's a lot of random factors that come into play in life,
whether it's with car accidents or meteor impacts or disease,
you name,
name,
name it,
fill in,
fill in the blank.
But we don't know that.
And there's a lot of things about being a person that are very strange.
There's a lot of things about our interactions with each other,
about energy,
about the,
the amount of energy you put out and what you get back,
the way you interact
with humans.
And how do we not know that those things in some way or another,
the way you interact with people,
flavor,
not just your relationships with those people,
but the entire reality that you live in.
It's very possible that there's more flexibility and that the world is more
malleable than we think it is and that we have everything defined in terms of
what something weighs or how much distance this is,
but these are just sort of crude static factors in a constantly changing and
moving world and the human mind interacting with that world might be,
might be much more significant than we think it is and it's one of the reasons
why these ideas of quantum entanglement becomes so strange when you find out
about these theories of quantum mechanics and quantum physics and string theory
and super particles in super position where they're moving and not moving at the
same time,
thing's blinking in and out of existence.
So the lowest measurable portion of of the universe that we can find the lowest
measurable,
like the smallest tiniest thing.
It's magic.
It's all magic.
The,
when you get into quantum mechanics,
when you get into string theory,
subatomic particles,
when you get into like really complex mathematics and and,
and different experiments that they do on the smallest,
tiniest,
measurable parts of the world,
it's all magic.
It's all empty space.
Me Atoms are mostly empty space inside these subatomic particles,
they,
they're moving and they're still at the same time.
They blink in and out of existence.
They go somewhere and they disappear and then they come back.
We have no idea where they go.
We just know they go somewhere.
They exhibit magic.
The lowest measurable part of the universe itself is magic.
The smallest portions that we can measure our magic.
So just because everything is big and this table's made out of oak and this
microphone is metal,
that doesn't mean shit.
I mean,
it means shit.
If I hit you over the head with,
this is going to fucking hurt because that's the rules we've chosen.
Right?
But the,
the actual reality itself,
it's very malleable.
There's a lot of weirdness to the world.
I don't think Melissa Etheridge is totally right.
I think there's a lot of hubris involved and thinking that you have the answer
and that you use thinking good thoughts and you know this plane is never going
to crash.
I don't,
I don't believe that.
I mean this is coming from also from a person who was suffered from cancer.
So it's like,
it's like I don't,
you know,
I don't,
I think,
I think it's a self serving philosophy to think that way.
Yeah.
You might be right,
but to say you're right.
I think it's crazy.
Yeah.
And you,
you,
you can't dictate.
I mean I think it positive thinking is a good thing too.
It's not all safe cause you walked in the room.
But it might be,
that's what's fucked.
It might not be,
might be meaning it might be because it's her or it might because of,
cause if anybody,
anybody,
anybody who thinks a certain way,
anybody who lives their life with it,
it sounds like bullshit.
But trust me,
if people are going crazy right now listening to this,
I agree with you.
It's sounds like bullshit.
Most likely it's not true.
But it might be true.
We can't prove that it's not.
We don't know all of the interactions that the human mind and consciousness have
on the universe itself.
We don't know.
We assume that it's simple as you are responsible for your life,
you're responsible for your actions.
You're responsible for where you drive and where you go to school and what comes
out of your mouth.
We assume that that is just a part of the mathematical interaction of human
beings in this culture and this society and the civilization,
but we're not totally sure that it is possible that you were thinking and that
your mind itself might affect reality because the reality that you see in the
reality that I see is just what's in front of us.
We assume that this is constantly going on behind the scenes.
We assume you assume that when you go to home,
when you uh,
you go home and you sit in front of the TV,
you assume I exist until I text you.
You don't know for sure until you call me or we meet and we high five and get on
a plane,
go,
go tell some jokes.
We don't know that that we exist.
We just assume based on the evidence that I've accumulated when when I go home,
I assume that you Tommy buns live your life,
but I don't know what the fuck you do.
The whole thing could be a joke.
My life could be non real in your world.
I could be just what happens when you come around the program that is Joe Rogan.
Right?
I might not be real you.
You leave this room and you go out and this whole thing might shut down
and the only time it turns on is when you're watching sort of like the
difference between particles being observed and not being observed.
They have,
they exhibit different behavior because they're interacting with whatever the
fuck it is that measures them.
It all goes back to reality is what you make of it.
Maybe.
Yeah,
maybe.
But I mean,
you know,
you can really,
if you dig,
if you decide to live your life within that thought,
that reality is what I make of it.
You know,
you dictate everything,
you know?
In a lot of ways.
Yeah.
You'll a lot of ways.
He do.
You didn't,
when people die,
they always say they see the light and they always see I,
you know,
when they come back to life,
when they die,
they always see the light.
They always see it.
Like I saw my family was all there and it was all cloudy.
People are smoking weed.
What if?
What if that was just you waking up going,
oh yeah,
this was a whole program that I did and my family's here and we're all just,
well that's a joke that I used to do right about the aliens about like,
well that's what the simulation theory,
what it really is.
The reason why aliens exist.
That's us,
aliens or us in the future and what we are is where people that fucked up and we
evolve too far.
We,
we eliminated all the fun out of the world.
We eliminated sacks,
blowjobs muscle cars,
cigarettes,
we exhibit,
we took out Whiskey,
we eliminated all human conflict and what we're,
what are we left with?
We're left with boring bullshit.
We don't have bodies with these weird stick bodies anymore.
We don't have dicks.
We somewhere along the line,
people realize that Dixon vaginas are causing fucking problems.
Girl,
there's,
there's too many women out there that are getting pregnant to keep a man.
There's too many men out there that are rate bang.
There's too much nonsense.
It's too many people that are having babies that really don't support these
children correctly.
And so sex and sexual urges being what's responsible for breeding.
We got to,
we got to factor that out.
We've got to take that out of the equation.
So one day they,
they got everything
changed and evolved to a point where they eliminated all the variables in the
world.
The Olympic,
they have too much power and they eliminated eliminated sex and emotions and we
don't like it.
So when we plug ourselves in two and a simulated version of the roaring twenties
of the digital age,
it's not a coincidence that we are at this moment in time,
the craziest moment the world has ever known where the world and the universe is
constantly changing every second of every day.
It's not a coincidence at all.
In fact,
this is what we asked for.
We asked to be born in this time.
We,
we right now,
I mean,
as I said this on stage a Friday night,
but I,
I,
I believe it,
we live in the greatest time to be alive ever.
This is the strangest,
wildest,
most,
the most possible,
most possibility filled time in life.
There's so many things going on constantly.
There was something in the news today that the first monkeys were born that have
they altered the genetics of them?
They're here.
I'll pull it up on,
on,
on Twitter.
Cause this is such a strange,
strange,
um,
scientific experiment and people that when I posted it,
everybody's like,
wait a minute,
isn't this how fucking planet of the apes got started?
But it is a planet of the apes guys started these idea,
first monkeys with customized DNA programmed genetic mutations.
So they are programmed genetic mutations and these monkeys were born.
So they,
they,
they're working on creating a perfect monkey.
They're going to alter the genes of these monkeys and they're going to continue
to alter genes of the monkeys until essentially they have a monkey that's a
smart as a fucking person.
Really or a monkey that has a giant Dick or a monkey that grows wings and flies
like a bat.
This program's in place.
This is something that's being monkeys are born,
these monkeys are born.
We live in a fantastic time and the idea being that what the aliens are,
when everybody has these archetypal experiences,
it's always these things that look very similar to what you would expect human
beings to eventually become.
If you go back to the lower hominids,
go back to monkeys.
You go back to chimpanzees,
you go back to the great apes and you look at them in comparison to us.
What do you see?
Well,
they have more hair.
They look much stronger.
They're more veer,
more,
much more physically fit.
You take the average person that say it works in an office,
the average man,
and you compare them to the the great apes.
They're all fat and they're skinny.
They have no muscle like what is going to be next?
What's going to be next?
Well,
what's going to be next is that we're going to continue the trend to not need
bronze,
to not need biological strength.
The brains are going to get bigger telekinesis,
the ability to control things with the mind,
the ability to talk without using language,
so the mouth is going to shrink up.
The environment's going to be all fucked,
so you're going to have to need builtin sunglasses.
You get these fucking gigantic black eyes that are going to fall off because
we're going to ruin our fucking atmosphere.
I mean,
they literally are what we'd expect us to look like a million years from now.
We would expect human beings to slowly but surely evolve into that.
If we used to be hairy little furry rodents,
which is what we were,
the idea of,
you know,
there was no primates 65 million years ago,
okay?
When the great extinction event happened that killed off the dinosaurs,
the giant piece of rock from the sky that hit the Yucatan.
There was no primates,
primates,
somehow or another evolved out of that of the shrews and the monkey and the rats
and wherever the fuck survived,
whatever mammalian life form survived.
So crazy to think of.
That's the only 65 million years ago,
man.
That's as far back as we know for sure.
There was no people.
No,
no,
no way.
No how,
and it's a blink of an eye.
That's in terms of the universe.
It's a blink of an eye 65 million years ago.
Yeah.
So were so positive that things got wiped out at 65 million years ago.
So positive,
so positive.
That's when the dinosaurs died off.
So from then on,
somehow or another people were created.
That's nothing.
Yeah,
that's a goddamn blink of the eye.
And if you look at how much different we look than the early monkeys,
what,
what's next?
This is aliens is next.
That's next.
It's 100% next.
That's what you would think that if we're going to continue this trend of no
hair,
hair loss on the arms and the body,
people are getting less hairy,
people are getting less strong.
There's was getting smaller.
You're using your fingers and eventually going to use Google glasses so you
could just kind of talk to it.
Eventually gonna be able to read your mind so you don't have to talk your
fucking vocal.
Carl's going to shrink up.
We're gonna all agree to genetically alter ourselves so we don't have penises
anymore.
As soon as they come up with a fucking thing that you could program into that
takes you in a wild sexual ride of simulation that you could never achieve with
your actual real dick,
you'd be like,
I don't need this stupid thing anymore.
Your Dick is going to be just as dumb as a horse.
Your Dick is going to be like something that you like.
Remember when people used to fuck with dicks?
Ah,
you got to laugh about it.
Just like sending a fucking pigeon with a note wrapped around it's leg,
but how to do that when I can text you.
You wouldn't.
You wouldn't,
but what about the actual having to writing in your hand.
Get the fuck Outta here.
The doodle.
Send me a selfie with a big smile and a thumbs up and it gets me in one second.
I have to rely on some stupid pigeon.
That's going to be what sex becomes.
Sex is going to become some silly thing that we don't need to do anymore because
we're going to have some integrated pleasure system that's in our mind.
Where are we going to be able to just go the fuck anyone you want,
man,
you're going to be able to have insane sex with Christie Brinkley when she was
21 you're going to be able to,
you know,
to,
to fuck the harness woman on the planet.
You're gonna be able to have sex with beyond a hundred beyoncé's.
The Wu Tang clan a room,
the whole Wu Tang clan is going to suck your Dick.
Awesome.
Whoever you want.
You're going to literally be able to do whatever you want whenever you want to
do it.
Once they figure out,
look,
this oculus rift thing,
what we're seeing when we see oculus rift is like the first photograph you ever
see those like first photographs of these to have like a thing they would throw
like a pack,
a tent over there back.
They'd be hiding in this box.
You know like you ever seen that you really old cameras,
the way they throw like a towel over the top of their head and they would point
this thing and everybody had to stay still for like a minute.
Sit there.
Don't fucking move.
Yeah.
That's what we're seeing with oculus rift.
What do you think physically will be the evolutionary change of humans?
Those shrink.
We're shrinking.
We're eventually going to get to the point where we don't need,
well when people are getting much bigger now,
but that's because of protein,
the protein intake because people understand diet better and as far as athletes
you got,
you're dealing with hormonal manipulation,
growth hormone,
testosterone.
You're also dealing with massive scientific advances and strength and
conditioning training.
And then also there's some selective breeding,
big people dating big people.
There's that Christie Brinkley,
she's heard today 60,
she's jamming.
Do you got to see her moving around too?
It's not an illusion.
It's an illusion created by the a,
the photograph.
I mean,
she definitely looks like an older mature woman,
but I would send it home,
send it home,
send it home.
I'd have to be real careful.
Yeah.
Cause I am a fucking animal.
You know what I'm saying?
And they get hurt her,
that hip strength.
I've got lower back muscles that thick Fords,
hip,
a kettlebell swings,
all that shit.
I do a lot of those.
I do a lot to do with Christie Shit,
but well,
they're going to get to a point where I'm going to be able to reverse aging.
That's on.
Unquestionably.
They're working on that and they're,
they're already like doing tests on that,
on,
on other animals.
I feel like this path is going to lead us to just be born and just lay down with
a fucking monitor in front of us.
Like,
uh,
and just you sip your fighter nutrients and up and never stand up and just plug
into whatever you want to be.
We can get our nutrients the same way those a wireless pads are.
When you know,
you take one of those new cell phones,
we get to sit in on something and it just charges,
you don't even have to plug it in.
That's how we're gonna get our nutrients.
Are nutrients going to be delivered through our car seats as we drive to work,
we're going to get nutrients drive to work naked and the nutrients are going to
just be absorbed by your body.
Skin.
I mean,
why not your skin?
I mean there's like rub testosterone cream on testosterone cream absorbs through
your skin.
They're going to fuck and you're going to be able to sit,
sit in your little Honda on your way to work and your car is going to feed you
and you believe it and no,
no shipping,
no farting,
no farting.
Yeah.
And if you want to like feel like a Henry the eighth orgy of food and big
fucking Turkey legs,
he just programmed that punching that and take you one of uh,
Germany to Henry of the eighth land.
You'll,
you'll die in a gigantic oak table with enemy heads hanging from the fucking
ceiling.
It's pretty awesome to think of like all,
all the worlds you could create and just jump into it in a second.
It's coming,
dude.
Yeah.
We just,
we are just so comfortable with the world that we live in now.
It seems so normal to us,
but you have a,
you have a lamp on your table over there.
You got a Goddamn a lava lamp sitting next to you.
It's weird.
Gooey shit is bouncing up and down and someone figured out a way to have
electricity.
The shit that creates lightning come through the walls in these weird pipes.
Yeah,
you got the wrong one.
They're silly face.
You can't say it.
Push that in front of the,
push that in front of the salt lamp.
Pull it that thing over so people could see what we're talking about.
That shit.
It's grabbing the bottom of the bottom of it.
Yeah.
That's how it's going to fall.
It's not going to fall.
Look at that thing.
If you brought that thing back in time,
if you brought that thing just as simple as stupid lava lamp,
if you brought that back in time and showed someone from King Arthur's time,
they'll kill you.
Definitely.
Jeans or pants.
Yeah,
my Lord.
Yeah.
She has electricity in the walls.
This lightning in the walls.
We're going to die.
You're going to die.
Stick a fork in that hole in the wall and you're dead.
Every person has a hole in the,
in their house.
We stick a fork in you.
You're dead.
Yeah,
they crazy,
isn't it?
It's ridiculous.
We might not die.
I mean,
you might just get really fucked up.
I gotta let me as a kid,
I stuck a key into an outlet.
Oh my God.
I don't know how the,
I guess the had maybe the shutoff circuit breakers.
Right,
but I stuck it in.
Sparks flew,
I mean flew out of it.
The key broken half,
like the burnt end state in the burn chart.
And it broken.
I was just like,
ah,
I think I fucked up in here.
Like
parents came in,
same thing,
but I took a wire.
My idea is it's going to transfer electricity from the top outlet to the bottom
outlet.
It's like put it in there.
And I remember my dad was watching incredible Hawk at the time cause that's why
I was in the kitchen hiding and putting it in the wire sparks and fire.
It felt,
it felt like there was fire by shows us that if we had done that in like the
50s,
we just be dead probably.
Right.
Well if you had done that during the,
during the days
of direct current,
it would have been very different.
Very different.
Yeah.
Like um,
they,
do you remember the uh,
Thomas Edison experiments?
They did when Thomas Edison was trying to warn people against the effects of
alternating current,
they,
they cooked an elephant.
They hooked this elephant up to this,
like these wires and barbecue.
This elephant.
No,
he never seen that.
It's pretty crazy.
A Thomas Edison.
Interesting cat.
You know,
because obviously great genius and inventor and responsible for a lot of uh,
pretty incredible things.
Yeah.
But also like was doing battle with the concepts that were being endorsed by
other scientists.
Like even Nikola Tesla was an alternating current guy.
He believed in the alternating current and Edison was,
his whole thing was set up on direct current.
So if you,
if you watch it,
pull that video up cause it's fucking crazy.
Like this is again,
when you think about human beings,
it's not that long ago man.
You know,
I mean this is a,
what was it?
19 what?
When did this happen?
Uh,
1903 1903.
So this is when people were just starting to figure out what the fuck
electricity could do and they have this elephant stretch chained up.
And Thomas Edison's like,
look,
I'm going to show you guys what happens if you don't fucking listen to me.
So he did this just to disprove the other guys.
Yes.
But watch what he does.
They have this thing connected to this and they just charge it up and zap this
elephant.
Look,
he's cooking right now.
Damn these poor Elfant and just stand there and boom,
it falls over dead.
Oh Damn.
And that's in your house,
that's in your walls.
And Edison was trying to let you know like,
listen to me bitch.
Like what a crazy fuck that guy is.
He didn't just try to prove it with science.
He said,
okay,
I'm going to show you.
I'm going to take something bigger than you and I'm going to cook it.
I'm my cooking one night.
Tricity who second?
So what's not.
So that must have been like a huge like wave of fear and paranoia.
After that,
they cooked the fucking elephant with his new type of electricity because in
that case,
what did he hooked it up?
He cooked it.
They covered it with wires.
I mean the,
the connected it with wires and then it fucking just electrocuted the shit out
of his Christ.
That was Thomas Edison.
Could you imagine if in 2014 okay,
if you know,
a hundred plus years later,
they did that.
The imagine if someone tried to prove something,
if they tried to prove,
you know,
there's,
we are on the verge of wireless electricity.
Ladies and gentlemen,
in order to tell you what is wrong with a wireless electricity,
here's,
you know,
Marty mcfuck face and Marty mcfuck face.
The scientist shows us.
Here we are in Times Square.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this is an elephant is connected to this receiver and we're going to broadcast
wireless electricity to his brain.
Watch.
What happens is poor elephant fucking ears to outstrip.
Yeah,
I start to bleeding from his eyeballs and falls face first.
Peta would be all over it.
Everyone would freak that dog killed immediately.
They would kill him,
kill him.
If they didn't kill him,
they would beat him.
They would torture them to the end of the time.
He's an asshole.
He's,
he,
he's not even,
you're not even eating an elephant.
You know,
it's not like a cow like that.
You,
you,
you electrocute it and then you eat it.
You know,
you're just killing it.
Just killing it to prove a point.
That's just a hundred plus years ago.
It's really not long ago at all.
If you really stop and think about how much different people are,
2003 it was or well,
not a to know.
Three rather.
Yeah,
1903 and think that too.
Behaviors change so much.
If you,
if you measure by decades,
it's crazy how much,
how about you mentioned by movies when the Menus,
a slap women across the face all the time.
Shut up woman,
James Cagney heroes,
heroes,
heroes.
Sheroes used to smack women right across the face.
John Wayne style.
Get a hold of yourself
and the woman would just stand there and take it and then they start making out.
That's Sean Connery and the interview talking and we've seen that,
right?
If she doesn't listen,
listen,
we mac back around.
He was saying that women have a way of like getting you to do that.
Dude,
you're dating the wrong bitches.
Smacking him.
I'm pretty sure you're dating the wrong women.
Oh,
women don't do that.
So know you're choosing to date that that style of person,
like yeah,
there were people 200 years ago that wouldn't cause you to hit them.
No.
Okay.
There wouldn't torment you.
Not everybody wants to be constantly in conflict.
It's like it's such a stupid state.
He's drawn to the conflict.
That's why you want to do once.
It is awesome as he is an actor,
he's an actor,
but he also,
you know,
he's coming from a different era for sure.
And he,
but he looked at a,
I think it was Barbara Walters,
he was like,
I'm gonna smack you next.
If you keep that shit up,
he looks it up so we can watch that business.
A fucking Sean Connery saying she'd hit women.
I mean it's this,
and this happened a long time ago.
It's 2020 plus now,
maybe.
Yeah,
25 to 30 years ago.
I'm guessing.
Obviously not a long time ago in terms of what we've been saying,
the entire podcast,
but,
but he's an old school dude.
He's got to be in his late seventies or something by now.
Right.
But what I'm saying is like,
you couldn't do that today.
Hell No.
Like the,
the,
the culture has evolved,
but you get what I'm saying.
I wouldn't do that for the years.
Go by.
The worst thing to slap a woman now and then as I remember you said you don't do
it with phase change.
It's better to do it with an open hand.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Yeah.
I love that.
I wouldn't change my opinion.
What did she say?
I would love that.
Is that what she said?
Hold on a second.
Hold on.
What did she say
first?
It's better to do it with an open hand.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Yeah.
I didn't love that,
but didn't love it.
No,
I didn't love you think it's good to slap a woman?
I don't think it's good.
I don't think it's bad that I don't think it's that bad.
I think that it depends entirely on the circumstances and if it marriage,
you have tried everything else and women are pretty good at it.
They can't leave it alone.
They don't want to have the last word.
Then you'd give them the last one,
but they're not happy with the last one.
They want to share it again and,
and get into a really provocative situation.
Then
I think it's absolutely right.
What's up?
Ruin a good interview.
But the idea behind that is fascinating.
Yeah.
I mean,
all he's really saying is I don't like a yappy broad.
Yeah.
And that's really what he's trying to say.
You need to bring her up with a dude.
Just,
they're not all like that.
So crazy.
Not all men are like that and not all women are like that.
You know what's so great about that?
The only great thing about that is,
you know,
when you call somebody out,
he,
she was calling him out on national television and his,
uh,
his defense instincts kicked in,
or when she said,
uh,
she was like,
he realized were probably just having a nice chat.
She brings that up and he was like,
immediately his face changed and he goes,
yeah,
I haven't changed my position on that.
Like,
he was really like,
I'm going to do battle with you now.
Yeah.
He likes conflict as a guy who wants to,
he wants to have conflict.
Well,
I think,
I think he's just really confident and I think he believes in what he's saying
and uh,
he thinks it.
Barbara Walters just trying to catch him and you know,
expose that and have him back down and was like,
I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna back down.
You're not going to back down.
Yeah.
I date crazy bitches and sometimes I have to smack him back tomorrow.
Those are the ones who like to fuck,
fuck,
like wild animals.
And that's what I need in my life.
I'm 60 years old and I didn't get my dick hard and he's not very young creaming
bitch that,
you know,
let's me send it in.
Yeah.
No,
he's not,
not young.
They're young man.
You know,
some,
some people the,
the aphrodisiac,
like the stimulant is not just sexual,
it's not just how the person looks,
it's not just being attracted to them.
Sometimes it's drama.
You know,
like there's a lot of people that get sucked up into this idea of fighting and
then making up and then to make makeup sex.
Yeah,
it's super common because we all have been there before where you break up with
someone and you're like,
it's over.
It's like fucking devastating.
It's heartbreaking.
And then one day you run into them and it might be just a month later or two
months later or whatever it may be.
You both have dated other people,
whatever.
And then you hook up and it's incredible.
The sex is incredible and you're nice to each other and you're like,
I'm sorry,
I'm sorry to,
and you,
and it's incredible,
but it's such a heightened kite type of sex,
makeup,
sex.
Cause sometimes people need to put things into perspective.
They need the um,
the benefit of time.
They need the benefit of having all these emotions run through your head,
having all this,
these bad feelings,
but then having them all slow down and relax and time puts things into
perspective and you know,
and then you see each other,
then you're like,
oh fuck.
And all you can think of then it's like the good times.
It's real hard to think about these really stupid,
petty bad times and relationships once the relationship is over.
You really mostly just think about the good stuff about that person.
Right.
That's then used to start fucking again.
Oh Shit Dude.
I Bet Sean Connery through his deck around a lot.
Back in over time.
But then again,
what happens after that?
You get fucking tired of each other again and you fall back new same old ways
and you get tired with each other and how do you fix that ladies and gentlemen?
Marijuana.
That's right.
Smoked some weed and fuck.
And you appreciate each other like,
like,
yeah,
just met.
That's good.
That's good advice.
Great Advice.
There's no,
no better like enhancement to sex than marijuana.
The people who fuck and don't smoke pot.
You are missing out on 50% of your sex.
Yeah,
you really are.
You don't know what you're missing.
It's if,
if I could give you something that's not dangerous and that will make sex 50%
better,
do you know what that would be worth on the open market?
I mean,
there's stupid pills that you take that are supposed to make your Dick Rowe that
don't do a goddamn thing.
There's stupid people out there that are cut and rhino horns off to make their
cocks hard.
That doesn't work.
There's so much money in like enhancing sex and the number one thing to enhance
sex,
it just flies under the radar.
The one thing that works like a charm,
if you are in love or you are in lust or you have someone that you'd like to
fuck,
how about that?
And that person likes you to fuck them.
Get together and smoke some pot before you do it.
Don't get crazy.
Don't,
don't smoke so much.
You're paranoid and you freak out and he can't get it up just a little bit.
Just a little bit.
Every touch will feel more,
more spectacular.
You'll feel like electricity through fingers.
The warmth of your bodies will,
the sensation would be so pleasurable.
People that don't smoke pot and fuck,
you're missing out on that Cheyenne Chunk of what sex is.
Yeah,
or do it,
you know,
smoke and go touch a stranger or do mushrooms.
You want to go deep,
deep,
deep.
Have sex on machine.
Ever done that you'll like to kaleidoscopes.
It's hard to do.
Colliding so hard to do.
It's really hard to do.
I like,
I was fucking,
that's really tall girl lines and I was on mushrooms and I thought she was an
alien.
I was like,
I had just my,
it just cause you start playing tricks on yourself.
Play tricks on you and stuff.
I don't want to do that.
Don't,
don't listen to it.
You don't.
You won't think you're an alien deal with your wife's not nailing crazy.
Yeah.
Look,
obviously the way you get affected by mushrooms is different than the way I do.
I think everybody is different.
That's a,
that's one of the weird things about psychedelics or pod or anything,
so thanks everybody.
Yeah,
I've heard people talk about what pot does them and I'm like,
okay,
I don't know what's going on in your head,
but that's not me.
Shuts me down.
I just don't want to talk to anybody to sit down and shuts me down.
All right.
Okay.
I don't get it,
but maybe is everybody's got their own weird personality trends strand that you,
you know.
Well,
I just think there's a lot of a weird personality,
Trump traits.
You know,
there's a lot of weird biological traits.
People have a lot of different things going on.
People with alcohol,
I mean there's people that are the worst drunk ever that are super nice people.
And then there's also people that they're,
they have a couple of drinks and they just become friendlier.
Nothing goes wrong at all.
I know,
it's really fascinating because I look back,
there's like a friends that would like want to punch me.
You learn after like a few not,
cause I did something like every time they drank they were physically violent
people and like Jesus Christ.
And then there's the person who's just like hugging you.
I love you man.
You're like,
but they had the same amount of drinks and this is the behavior that comes out
too bad almost makes you,
it bums you out like,
Oh man,
you can't drink like you really,
we can't have you drinking.
Yeah.
And that's not uncommon at all.
No,
no.
It's probably like one out of 100 people.
Less than that,
I think last year.
Yeah.
That's like a food allergy almost.
Well that was something that they,
uh,
another thing that I had up on Twitter today that's pretty fascinating about
food allergies.
They figured out a way to,
uh,
to fix kids,
allergies to peanuts.
Really.
The DNA of peanut allergic kids changes with immune therapy study finds.
Hmm.
That's cool.
And this is on science daily.
So this is again not like a goofy website.
It's from Stanford.
And the idea is that treating a peanut allergy with oral immunotherapy changes
the DNA of the patient's immune cells according to a new study.
The DNA change could serve as the basis for a simple blood test to monitor long
term effectiveness of the allergy therapy.
That's pretty bad ass man.
He was a lot of fucking foods that people are allergic to.
Some people are definitely allergic to shellfish.
We had that on fear factor of this dude.
Um,
some roaches and roaches are,
um,
they have the same enzyme,
apparently a shellfish.
So if you're allergic to roaches or even you don't know if you're allergic to
shellfish,
you'll also allergic to roaches.
Really?
Yeah.
So let's do like had like went into like Anna Filactic shock kind of.
Well,
he had started a,
his throat started closing up.
Yeah.
He was having a hard time breathing.
Well swelling,
you know,
that's what happens.
He had no idea or he knew he probably was a shellfish guy but didn't think about
the Roche.
Well we didn't know.
Nobody knew.
I mean,
yeah,
it was the early days of fear factor.
Wow.
Yeah.
That shows just so lucky that no one died.
So lucky that dude definitely could if you didn't have a right medics around,
you know,
what are you guys doing over there?
What's going on?
Uh,
70 bags of heroin founded and Philip Seymour Hoffman is apartment poor fucker.
He just got back on it,
right?
Like a couple of years ago.
He was like really clean up for like most of his life.
And then he just,
he had a problem a while ago.
Yeah.
Then he was clean for a while and then they talked about him going,
I remember reading about him going to get help.
Like,
I wouldn't say within the last year to do something,
you know,
like some type of rehab thing in the last year and then uh,
yeah,
that's really a bummer man.
Well the thing about him too is he died with a needle in his arm and his arm.
Yeah.
So he really,
he over did it.
Well,
he just did it.
He's not the only one either that's dying.
Apparently there's quite a few people have died in the east coast,
Maryland recently.
Yeah.
They're thinking is a,
there's a bad batch of heroin or a strong batch of heroin or something.
Wow.
He was so good.
Holy Shit.
Was he a talented actor?
That guy,
man.
Unbelievable.
Well,
I think that some of the people that are able to like encapsulate those
incredible characters,
he able to fit themselves into those characters.
A lot of those people are fucking crazy.
Like Robert Downey jr crazy.
You know,
it would go off on wild benders and do drugs.
Like there's a lot of those people that are like really good at acting.
There are sort of attracted to that.
Then that chaos and war.
Maybe it's just a part of what makes them a great actors.
You're really,
if you're a great,
great actor,
you have a sensitivity that's like maybe heightened,
you know,
you're sensitive.
I mean emotionally all around.
And um,
you know,
sometimes when you have that sense of you can be drawn in and certain other
directions,
you know.
Yeah.
So,
but he a man Hoffman was just genius actor.
Yeah.
He was a bad motherfucker.
You know,
it's sad when you see a guy like that just to come to their demons,
you know,
really is too bad.
That's a weird one too,
that heroin one's a weird one,
you know,
because people are talking about like legalizing all drugs.
All drugs should be legal.
And it a way I support that.
But in another way I'm like,
it would suck to see more people do heroin.
It really would.
Crystal meth because what I'm seeing now with pills,
I've met several people.
I know several people.
I know one guy very well that died from pills.
I know one guy,
uh,
very close to my family who fucked up his entire life on pills and he's still a
mass and he used to be a great guy and he's just a rack and it's all opiates,
all opiates,
you know,
and then you see this guy and you go like,
fuck man.
Like if it was illegal,
would it be even more prevalent?
Like I would hope not,
but God,
it's just,
I'm not,
I'm just anti heroin.
I think heroin's a terrible drug to live your life with.
It just,
yeah.
There's nobody really who was like doing well thriving with heroin.
You know,
the crazy thing is how long some people can function.
Yeah.
And there's people that can function and there's people that actually probably
never get to the point where they're not able to function.
You know,
there's people that can keep it in check,
but I think for the most part,
um,
it just goes down hill for you.
Well,
one of the problems with these pill people is that they're not even trying to
get high.
They're trying to not be sick.
Right.
Cause your body's craving it.
Yeah.
You get so addicted to these opiate pills that your body is just trying to get
to a base level.
It's not trying to,
it's not trying to get high as much as it's trying to get out of a deficit.
So you give it these pills and then you like sort of feel normal for awhile.
Yeah.
It's just so scary.
Yeah,
it is.
I mean,
I knew somebody who had a bad drinking problem and,
and would like when went into,
you know,
withdrawal would drink never really to get drunk.
It was because there's sewage,
such an alcoholic that,
you know,
she would drink just to Maine,
like to not be shaking and sweating.
Yeah.
That's what I've don't,
I don't understand because I,
I,
I've had many drinks.
Yeah.
I don't get the alcohol one.
I don't understand how that could be addicted to somewhat addictive to somebody
for,
yeah.
But I do understand,
obviously it's a matte painting.
Many people are addicted to it,
but just for me,
it's just,
I don't understand.
It just seems,
uh,
it's just so strange that their body is craving alcohol.
Like it's a,
it's not just,
uh,
an emotional thing.
I mean,
they say that that's what happened with,
um,
an Amy Winehouse that she died from going cold Turkey.
Really?
Yeah.
She only had alcohol in her system when she died.
She didn't have any drugs and with her body just went into this.
I suspect that she tried to quit drinking and it just,
uh,
Santa or over the edge.
Yeah.
That makes since I believe it,
man,
I,
I'm just glad I don't have that fucking,
that gene.
Yeah.
Or you know,
I mean,
I've never,
I drink once and if I drink once in a week and I'd have to major race,
I'm like,
man,
I'm not drinking it.
I don't drink again for like weeks man.
Really?
Yeah.
I haven't never,
you know,
that's just my own makeup.
When you used to hang out more locally at comedy clubs every night,
it used to probably go through that where you're like at a club every single
night.
Did you drink more back then?
Yeah,
not really because I never,
I never,
ever drank before sets.
So the most I ever did was drink after sets.
But if I was just doing spots and hanging out a little bit,
I'd be more worried about like,
you know,
I be worried about driving home.
So it wasn't a regular practice for me.
Like I've just never been that big of a drinker,
you know?
I mean,
I'll have more drinks on the road.
Um,
but sometimes a lot of times I go to clubs and,
um,
Saturday he'll be,
the first time I asked for a drink and they'll all say like,
oh,
we didn't know you drank.
And I'm like,
what were you talking about it?
And they're like,
yeah,
we thought that it was so weird that you don't drink.
And,
um,
you know,
I was like,
no,
I'm just done now.
You know?
So yeah,
alcohol is fun.
It's fun,
it's fun to drink.
It's fun to get drunk,
but the problem is the effect on your body.
It's just so bad.
And,
uh,
Tommy and I have been talking about this because for the last two weeks I
haven't drank.
Wow.
I tried to see what it's like to have nothing exciting.
I like glass of wine with dinner on Friday night,
but one glass of wine and that's it.
No like getting hammered.
No getting drunk.
No getting buzz,
no nothing.
Yup.
You,
you feel remarkably better.
You do Monday rolls around.
Remarkably.
So it's been two weeks in a row that I did this.
Like my endurance is up.
I mean it sounds so Duh.
You know,
it sounds so obvious,
but you just think if you're out at a comedy club,
you're hanging out with your buddies,
you won't do a shot.
Yeah,
fuck it.
Let's do a shot.
Let's do another one.
Okay,
let's have a beer.
Three or four drinks.
You feel like it's nothing and it really is nothing but a difference between
three or four drinks and no drinks.
It's pretty significant.
And how much better you feel?
It's,
it's tremendously different.
I mean a few weeks ago I had a few drinks and I
really feel like it took me like totally to recover was like 48 72 hours to feel
like a hundred percent better.
It was crazy.
It took like three days.
Yeah.
I feel that much better.
I never drank at home.
I only drink if I go out,
say like I,
I never said it home look like open up a beer or anything that unless it's like
at night and I'm the girls that were about to go to bed,
I need to have one more drink in her.
Oh,
how dare you
to a lot of feminists,
by the way.
Do you know that and aware of that?
Yeah.
They got to push that Mr. Conrad and shove that down your throat.
You're going to be a rapist.
But you know what's funny about that whole lot of feminist things that they're
saying that that works the other way around too with women and men that if the
man is drunk and the woman's so over,
the woman's raping the man,
I feel that way a hundred percent support that I had been raped.
They have to say that it ridiculous.
They have to say that they can't say there's a double standard.
Right.
Nobody wants to admit there's double standards.
It's double standards don't exist.
Especially in like the,
the super liberal left wing progressive world.
It's the same on both sides.
So I was watching,
I was reading this,
uh,
this person's blog where they were talking about everyone who has sex with
someone who's drinking is being a rapist.
And she was talking about men as well.
Like men being drunk.
That a woman taking advantage.
Yes ladies that is rape.
Like what are you talking about?
The guy has a few drinks,
he's buzzed and he comes over and he wants to fuck and you have sex with them.
You're a rapist.
That is so fucking dumb and so symptomatic.
So like symbolic of like what's wrong with that sort of rigid like liberal
thinking is this,
there are no debits.
The double standards,
I mean one of the major differences is that in that situation we are thrilled to
be raped.
It's not rape whether the man has a limited inhibitions or not.
That man wants to have sex.
If a guy comes to your house,
it's like if a guy goes to a bar,
gets drunk,
take a cab to your house,
let's make it a responsible story.
The guy takes a cab to your house and you,
uh,
throw him on the bed and fuck him.
That's not rape.
It's just not,
no,
it's just not.
It's just not and pretending that it is because you don't want women to be taken
advantage of.
And they'll like compared to like Steubenville,
like that the girl who was a,
she was so drunk that she was unconscious and these guys raped her.
Horrible,
unbelievably horrible,
unbelievably horrible and disgusting.
And it's a crime and it's evil.
Does the saying that a man being drunk is having sex with a woman?
Is that man being raped diminishes the impact of what's horrible about something
like Steubenville rape because you're being silly now.
Well,
you're,
you're saying something that is so preposterous that anyone with any logic could
immediately pick apart anyone who's had any experience.
Anyone who's a man,
by the way,
who's a heterosexual man who knows what it's like to have a couple of drinks and
uh,
and want to go have sex.
Like the idea that that is somehow or another race because you went over someone
who obviously you like,
you obviously liked this person,
you've,
I've obviously have it most likely have had sex with them before you go over
their house.
Yeah,
the Fuck Outta here.
I would even argue that if you,
if you're a man and you took a cab to that woman's house and she handcuffed you
to a bed and blindfolded you and put a ball gag in your mouth and fucked you,
that you also had a good time.
Like it wasn't,
it wasn't something that you were fighting,
you know,
or even able to getting tied up.
So it's on you fucker.
I mean other thing.
Yeah.
Have you ever been in a situation that where you felt like he had a girl in your
bed and he didn't want to have sex with her bed?
You're a man,
you have a girl in your bed.
What are you doing?
Like,
if you're a man,
you have a girl in your bed,
what kind of stupid game you playing can nine by now doing really me,
I just don't feel good about our relationship yet.
Shut up.
If you're a grown adult,
you're not a 10 year old.
You're not someone who's confused about biology and about sexuality and about,
you know,
stimulation and attractiveness.
No,
you're a fucking adult.
You can't get raped.
King of rape by a girl.
Jesus Christ.
Brian,
it's one thing if you like Brian,
the only thing that can be really crazy is if,
okay,
here's the scenario.
Um,
some sort of a survival situation where you're fleeing the country and you have
your friend's wife with you and you,
uh,
you have to stay in a hotel together because there's only a enough money for one
hotel room and just going to get some sleep and then get on the road and you're
like,
I'll sleep on the floor.
You take the bed and then while you're sleeping and you wake up and she's
talking to your deck,
you're like,
okay,
you just fucking ruined my life.
You ruined my life by being crazy and suck my dick while I'm sleeping.
Hey,
you know,
you kind of raping me.
Stop,
stop it.
I wouldn't have said Yes for you.
Suck on my Dick.
Or if I was awake,
wait,
wait a couple minutes now stop it.
That is probably one of the very few scenarios that I could see where there
could be argued that a woman rapes the guy.
Yeah.
There's kind of like,
uh,
what's,
what's the one,
it's a single white female.
They kind of have that,
that scenario.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Where pretends to be someone that she tries to pretend and she called and he's
like,
what's going on?
She's like,
well,
while she's choking on his cot,
and then he's like,
it's not even you.
So he got duped.
Right.
That's another one that's kind of rapey.
Yeah,
that's kind of rapey.
But that they'll finish and we'll talk about it,
but come on.
But a woman being drunk is always right.
If the woman's drunk there,
they want that to be raped and they want it.
I mean,
obviously there's a broad spectrum of,
of,
of intoxication.
You know like one drink,
two drinks,
three drinks for drinks.
One drink is you can make good decisions on one drink,
you can but you're drinking two drinks.
You could still make really good decisions on drinks but you're drinking.
So like if,
if you have sex with someone who can make good decisions and it's two drinks in
the idea that you say that's rape,
you're a crazy person,
you're a crazy person.
Like you're,
you're a person who's dangerous because you're fucking up the whole idea and
argument.
The whole conversation about alcohol intoxication,
you Rooney a bit by being unreasonable,
by taking this hard rigid stance,
you diminish the effect of something like Steubenville were where they are
getting someone so fucked up and taking advantage of someone who is so fucked up
and the way to kind of reel,
you know,
state your position is,
are you going to look at those two and say they're equivalent.
If you say they're equivalent,
then okay,
I guess we have your point of view on,
on,
you know,
the severity of,
of each of the,
but I think a reasonable person looks at those and you realize that they're not.
So it's kind of ridiculous.
Well,
it's a completely logical stance to take that.
It's a,
an on and off switch.
It's either on your,
there's an alcohol drink in,
in the system.
Uh,
it's,
it's that way.
It's rape.
There's no alcohol.
It's not rape.
Right.
Same Act.
Ridiculous.
Yeah.
There's,
it's clear that there's a certain point where someone is unable to make clear
decisions.
They're fucked up.
They're intoxicated.
But where that lies is,
is very blurry.
And it's different for every person.
Yeah.
And some not some girls,
God damn it,
a lot of girls like to get drunk and get fucked.
They'd like to have sex with people that want to have sex with when they have a
few drinks,
they like it a lot.
So the idea that people say that that's rape because,
because of whatever,
because you want to push this ridiculous progressive agenda.
And this idea that anyone having a couple of drinks is somehow or another so
incapacitated that they're like a child like the we have to protect them.
Yeah,
I guess they're not making the distinction that there's a difference between a
woman choosing to have drinks and go have sex and a woman who has had too many
drinks in someone is,
you know,
taking advantage of her.
I mean the two totally different things.
Well not only that,
there's also the woman and the man if they're both drinking,
right.
Then what happens when the woman is almost always in the clear,
no one is accusing her.
No one's saying,
you know,
this woman raped me.
I,
you know,
we had drinks together and she raped me.
How many drinks did you have?
Two.
How many drinks did she have to,
yeah man,
she raped you.
No one says that.
Right?
It doesn't say,
but I do say it to the guy.
He would say it to the guy like in the girl could say,
oh,
I got too drunk to consent and then you know,
toddler talk,
progressive think everybody's like,
oh,
it is rape.
To have sex with someone who's drinking.
No,
no,
it's raped sometimes to have sex with someone who's drinking is to say that
you're not responsible for your own actions sexually,
but you are.
When you're driving a car,
you are.
When you know you assault someone,
you know you're responsible.
If you kick someone's ass and hurt them and you're like,
I'm so sorry I was drunk.
You're responsible for that.
You are fucking responsible for your actions,
but you're not sexually.
You know,
if your girlfriend comes home and she's hammered and she beats the fuck out of
you and hits you over the head with a hammer and you go to the hospital,
your fucking heads gashed open.
She can't say I was drinking,
so I'm not responsible for that violence.
But if she comes over your house and she's drunk and cheap fucks you that,
then you're a rapist because you,
you didn't,
you,
you didn't take into account the fact that she's not responsible for our actions
cause she's had a couple of drinks.
It's madness.
It's so illogical and they,
they're so rigid on this because they want to support 100% women and women's
rights and the,
uh,
the idea of not supporting rape culture and the idea of diminishing rape and
society,
but by being so rigid and by being postural and illogical,
you ruin the whole discussion because we're on your side where you and I are
100% on,
on their side as far as like someone being drunk and you take advantage of that
person.
Right.
That's disgusting.
What they're trying to say is that there is no scale.
Exactly.
It's just,
it's black and white.
It's black and white.
You can't say that because you ruined the whole discussion.
You ruin it because we all know,
most of us know people who like to drink and fuck.
It's so common.
It's so normal,
you know,
drink to get frisky.
That's people are married,
they drink and they start making out and it's great.
Yeah.
It's not bad.
They loosened inhibitions,
so it's not bad.
The idea that alcohol is bad across the board for everybody is fucking stupid.
It's stupid.
It's just bad.
For your body.
That's what,
this is the only thing that you could prove for sure that's bad for your body.
It's just one of those weird things,
man.
Where people who are intelligent,
who have good intentions and there's good meaning behind what they're trying to
do,
they fuck it all up with their ego and they fuck it all up with their rigid
thinking and they fucked it all up because they're not being open and objective
about the entire discussion.
This situation.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's,
it's the same thing I feel like with judging a people as black and white.
Yeah.
I feel like most people are complex,
more complicated in varying degrees of good and bad.
And you know,
they're complicated.
Well,
you could easily put,
you know,
generalizations like there was a generalization,
um,
someone who was talking about standup comics and they were saying that a comedy
clubs are filled with angry men and that's what comic hubs are.
Okay.
That's a giant generalization.
What do you do?
What if Sarah Silverman,
Eliza slessinger on stage?
It's still angry men that are now,
it's silly.
It's silly.
Some comedians are angry men.
So are some mechanics.
Yeah.
So are so are some fucking bouncers.
There's some people that uh,
you know,
work in finance.
They're angry men.
Okay.
Some of them are,
aren't generalizations are fucking stupid.
They're gross.
So funny because when I hear those things,
like I always think of,
I'm thinking comedy comics that I know what always pops in my mind is just
silliness.
Yeah.
I don't think of like,
I think of like all the goofy,
silly kind of,
yeah.
You know,
like,
well,
last hanging out in the weekend.
What do we do?
Are laughing all the time.
We're laughing,
angry.
90% of the time we're not angry at shit.
You know,
the idea that,
I mean,
look,
we all know dudes who are,
we all know this,
but we all know an equal or more,
a greater amount of dudes who aren't like Norton.
We're hanging with Norton all weekend.
Norton's
fucking great.
He's an angry,
he comes off like fake angry for jokes,
for free,
for funny.
But he's filled with humility.
He's a very like,
uh,
self objective guy.
He's always like being introspective and talking about the way he behaves,
the way he thinks.
And he's always like criticizing himself,
you know,
and the idea that he's like this angry guy.
I was going to say that is that people also assume that um,
they'll say the anger,
the anger with a respect to like somebody doing something on stage and they'll
have no idea that that person's not like that offstage.
That that's a heightened
version of themselves for their act,
for humor,
for humor.
Like,
you know,
like Brian Holtzman,
who was one of my favorite comedians or for some whatever reason,
just it never really caught on with people he used to,
his whole act was this angry man who would say cruel,
evil shit and we would be dying laughing because he's not like that at all.
If you talked to Holtzman off stage,
he's laughing and he's shaking people's hands.
Hey ally.
Yeah,
what's going on?
Yeah.
Good to see you.
Hey,
good time up there.
You were really funny.
He's a funny guy.
But then he would do this character on stage where it was just like,
like Susan Smith,
when she drowned her kids,
he was like,
I heard those were bad kids.
Or those kids sat that close to the TV.
They didn't put away their blocks there were spilling their milk.
I was fucking,
kids were not be missed.
And it was so horrible but so funny how to be there to see it happen when the
tension was in the room.
Cause it was like two weeks after that woman drowned her kids.
You know,
that's a hilarious,
like a position to take that you have to commit her.
Those kids went bad.
That's how he says it.
They always fucking spelled that milk didn't put away their blocks.
I sat that closer to the TV.
Yeah.
Those kids will not be missed.
And the way he would say it was just so fucking,
the key to in like in those types of jokes is that you can never pull back on it
once you say it.
Yeah.
You gotta go all in.
Like now they were really bad.
Kept telling you.
I know,
you know?
Yeah.
You have to like believe what you're saying.
And it's not real.
No,
of course not.
That's the whole fucking,
that's why we know we can laugh at it.
It's a real issue with uh,
with progressive's this idea that you're going to silence that kind of thinking
and talking,
you know,
silence that kind of a,
those kinds of jokes.
And I see the point,
I see that you're trying to make a kinder,
gentler world for people to live in,
but I really feel like concentrating on jokes is a bad idea.
It is.
It's it,
it ruins the whole idea of trying to make people or at least diminishes the
whole idea of trying to make people in Nice in real life when they really mean
it and really care because you're not focusing on that.
Instead you're focusing on one,
they don't mean it and they're joking around like in the idea that somehow under
that joking around fuels the actual act,
the actual act of violence or the actual act of rape or the actual act of
anything evil or mean.
Because joking around about it is somehow or another gives a green light.
That's such a silly idea.
That's so silly.
If you have a problem with rape or if you have a problem with violence,
if you're a problem with a assaults,
do something that remedies the root cause of that and you'll find that it's not
jokes.
Nobody watched a comedy show was inspired to go rape somebody.
The idea behind that is fucking ridiculous.
The idea that it gives a green light,
you watch a comedy show and someone talks about beating the shit out of people.
It gives a green light to go out and beat the shit out of people.
That's no,
that's a defective person.
If that's the case,
you can't under their fucking mind.
You can't make your art only for defective people.
It's fucking stupid.
It is.
But it's a lot of that progressive mindset that this progressive black and white
mindset,
this left wing liberal mindset,
that it ruins those discussions because yeah,
we do need to be nicer to each other.
Fucking,
yeah,
for sure.
We need less racism.
Absolutely.
We need less sexism.
We need less assault.
We need less rape.
We need less violence.
We need last road rage.
We need less everything all across the board.
We need less of that.
But we're on your side and you're,
you're making us look like there's something wrong with us because we want to
drink and fuck.
You're making us look like there's something wrong with us because we enjoy a
ridiculous joke that someone doesn't really mean that's really cruel and nasty.
Yeah.
If you,
um,
if you really think that that comedy is the problem,
you're,
you're just gonna,
you're just going to make yourself look ridiculous.
You're going to get a very few people that agree with your point of view.
They're like,
yeah,
yeah.
Just get people to stop talking about anything that,
that could be offensive and you're just going to end up not making the progress
you are wishing for.
Yeah.
And the idea of trigger warnings,
that's the other thing.
Let's trigger warnings.
When people write blogs like super progressive,
uh,
people when they write blogs,
if they talk about rape or anything,
violence or crime,
they will put trigger warning in there.
A trigger warning like,
uh,
like to let you know that something horrible is coming up and it might trigger
posttraumatic stress like yeah,
if you say if you got beat up and robbed and someone's writing about,
you know,
like robbery and they'll,
they'll put trigger warning and like the title a trigger warning and the thing
and then explain what they're talking about so that you get warned that they're
going to talk about assault or there you get Warren,
they're going to talk about rape or sexual aggression or whatever the fuck it
is.
This trigger warning,
trigger warning.
Like it's,
it's a fascinating aspect of our society that you want to protect people from
just even thinking about something that might've happened to them that's been
upset you.
Yeah.
So though that subject,
whatever that subject is,
he's either off limits are severely limited because of the fact that someone
actually has been victimized and real life has kind of really ridiculous to me.
Fucking yeah,
it's for the well,
I mean cause you don't get trigger warnings when you're not doing it.
Aside from reading that fucking blog,
there's no trigger warnings on signs when you walk down the street.
There's no trigger warnings that when you have a conversation with somebody who
you might not know,
well,
they're not going to be like real quick.
In a moment,
I'm going to bring up fighting.
Just giving you a heads up.
Didn't trigger warnings be a trigger warning?
Like what didn't you think about rape?
If you give a trigger warning,
that wouldn't be a trigger warning,
but it would certainly be a trigger.
And you know every movie,
essentially every violent movie is a trigger.
A trigger to people who have experienced violence.
Of course,
every fucking television show on crime,
which almost all of them are.
I mean,
what percentage of television shows,
dramas or on crime?
What percentage of this Chicago police or CSI or this or CSI Miami,
New York,
CSI,
the moon,
there's fucking a hundred law and orders.
They're all on crime.
If you've experienced any violent crime in your life,
you know it's a horrible,
horrific,
traumatic event.
Post traumatic stress from crime victims is huge.
Yet every show on television that's a drama,
like a huge percentage of them.
It's probably like 30% of all late night or all a nighttime dramas are based on
crime.
Violent crime.
Murders to violence is so key.
It's so crazy when you,
when you watch
shows and they,
um,
they have violent scenes,
you know,
the edited version has the violent,
I can like a guy's getting his head fucking blown off and then they'll be like,
that's right bud.
You and you're like,
they just bleeped fuck you know,
that could,
we can't handle,
we can't handle hearing that tired of these hogwash.
And you're like,
well,
that's what he said.
No,
he said something else,
but we can't handle that.
But we did see him pull out a 12 gauge and blow the guy's fucking guts all over
the place.
Well,
how about the walking dead?
Watch the walking dead,
the walking dead.
They're cutting people's heads off.
They're blowing people's heads up with guns,
but they never say fuck.
Never say fuck.
It's,
yeah.
It's so redundant that you,
you know,
you can't also,
God forbid they show a woman's breasts that would make your hair.
No,
you can't do that.
No pussies at all.
No,
don't show me where the babies come from,
where the babies are made.
Can't handle it.
But you can show me a lady with a Samurai Sword.
It cuts people in half.
Yeah.
She kills regular people too.
She doesn't just kill zombies because regular bunch of the people kill regular
people.
They've killed a hundred bunch of regular people on that show.
It's fun.
Yeah,
but I can't handle hearing shit.
What the fuck man,
we're weird.
So weird.
What a stupid culture.
Well,
you know what?
I can't stop thinking about the guy,
the farted at the sink.
I think airport,
we talked about it for 10 minutes afterwards.
We'll Dude's Fart when they pee.
Go to the bathroom.
Do to constantly far to in public restrooms.
Yeah,
but at the sink and the dude was washing his hands and he cut a monster fart.
And I told Tommy about it and I was like,
dude,
this guy,
he broke,
he broke the rule.
I walked out just this happened.
I
unfortunately missed the incident,
but you said it immediately and I was,
I kept wrapping my head around it and I think what I've come to the conclusion
is that if you do that,
all I'm looking for is for you to acknowledge it.
Oops.
Yeah.
You need to say something.
I want you to say something about that.
Cause I was thinking about how,
uh,
an old guy one time farted next to me in,
um,
uh,
like on a tram and the in the airport and I was like,
Jesus,
he led a fucking pretty big fart.
And I looked at him and he goes,
snuck out of me.
I was like,
all right.
And I kind of took away like,
you know what was upsetting him?
It,
yes.
I was like,
well,
thank you for acknowledging your fart right now.
Yeah.
This guy was just washing his hands and he just,
the sink is not the year.
I don't think you'd get a pass there.
Yeah,
it was.
It was definitely,
it was definitely a gray area.
It was definitely a greater,
people fart all the time at the urinals.
That's so common.
Yeah.
I heard a lot of farms get done zip up walk all the way around washing your
hands in the middle of Washington as you just unload and no one said a word.
Yeah,
everyone just let it go.
And then we got outside and I was like,
Yo Dude,
how do you feel about this?
I can't stop thinking about it.
And then we're trying to figure out what kind of far it's girls cut when they're
in the bathroom and whether or not they washed their hands and far nine each
other.
Probably not as much.
Not as much.
But they definitely drop heat in there.
Once they close that door or then they allow themselves.
Yeah,
they allow themselves to,
to fucking farted up.
Um,
you know,
they let them rip once they get in that door that closed that door.
They just,
you have to,
if you're taking a shit,
you got to Fart.
But I wonder if they fart while they're washing their hands.
These are the things that I think I,
yeah,
absolutely.
I wonder about what we need more of this in the world.
Do you mask your farts when you shit in a public restaurant?
No.
Let it out.
You gotta do what you want.
Hold up to the Caliph girl farts in idiot.
Jesus Christ.
You have it on your phone.
I love girl farts.
40 year old man.
He's got it on his phone.
Oh
Christ.
Huge fetish now.
It's actually a weapon.
It is.
It's amazing.
It's been,
yeah,
it's amazing.
There's been fart porn forever.
We're dudes like sniff arts where you have a girl's ass.
Yeah.
I um,
naughty.
We played some,
a fart clips on our show and we were talking about it and the guy wrote in and
he was like,
I have a big time fart fetish.
And were like,
what?
Like what's the thinking about it?
And he was like,
I think it's just back to the taboo of it that the pretty girl is not supposed
to.
So he's uh,
you know what I mean?
Like did it say that should be in a dirty girl and he loves,
you know,
a pretty girl doing it is like the ultimate thing.
Yeah.
That's the thing about people is like,
they want people to be naughty,
right.
Just because we feel so,
most people at least feel so confined by the rules.
And I think women,
so even more so than men,
women even more so than men because society wants you to be a lady and he wants
a certain way.
Sure.
You know,
and there's slut shaming,
you know,
I have to be a slut.
You're not allowed to do what you want to do.
You know,
like if a woman wants to go out and fuck a bunch of different guys,
like we'll have one once a fuck two guys in at night.
She's a terrible person.
Like if you find out about that,
oh my God,
she,
and she went to this guy's house.
She fucked him.
Then she laughed and she went to this other guy's house and fucked him.
What a whore.
National Champion.
Like girls would be like,
what a whore.
Yeah.
But if you told me,
so he decides he leaves is this girl's house and he's like,
you know what?
Fuck I can call somebody else and you call somebody else and he goes and fucks
her.
And we're like,
that's great if as an animal.
Yeah.
It wasn't,
it wasn't even done.
He didn't want it to fuck more than,
that is crazy though that we don't,
you know,
that we have that,
that double standard for that.
I mean,
I remember in college a Guy Friend,
uh,
going into a sorority house and bang and girls in the same house in the same
nine different rooms and like,
yeah,
we all were like,
that's fantastic.
You're such a hero.
Like you're a wonderful person.
And I was like,
we were all so happy with his story.
But if a girl went to a fraternity house,
fuck one guy said goodnight honey left and then knocked on the door,
she's fucking under attorney fucking whore.
Yeah.
We really should applaud her.
I mean,
well or not,
either way we should let her do whatever she wants to do.
Yeah.
She's just fucking people.
Why do you,
what do you care?
Are they going to stay together forever during college?
Jesus Christ,
if you have a problem with the grow will fucks one guy and then fucks not the
guy that night.
You're silly.
Yeah,
you are.
What's wrong?
It could be one of those guys.
Yeah.
All you gotta do is throw your dig in front of her.
Obviously she likes him.
So that suppression leads to,
uh,
like a reaction.
This is just holding back leads to this need to let it go.
And the girl just forks right in that dude's face.
[inaudible]
if you do,
did you dirty bitch dirty 40 dash 40 bitch.
Pardon my mouth.
It's so funny.
The people that own this,
I love girlfriends are actually wants it right now.
Don't promote that so stupid.
Oh my gosh,
that's not Canada.
Me and I'm a bad girl.
The smell and the fucking noise and the whole thing that naughtiness of it all.
We hold it in Boston,
girls farting.
We have a thing about,
um,
about people shitting too.
You know,
like no one wants to admit,
they just took a shit.
We want to hide it and cover it up with noise and fans and we want to light
matches and yeah,
it,
it is weird.
I mean,
I don't like,
uh,
those single single stall Unisex bathrooms.
When you got to shit,
I got shit.
And then there's like,
someone's like,
you're going in there and you're like,
ah,
fuck man,
why don't you go in first to Shit on top?
Ain't shit.
I know I get,
but you get that,
you know,
like,
I feel like I can't relax or you can say,
can I please use the restroom?
Like if you're at a meeting,
if you're having a meeting or something like that and say,
I'll be right back off to use the restroom.
But you can't say,
look,
I got to shit.
I gotta I can't keep talking to you guys.
I gotta take a shit.
You say I use the restroom.
It's ambiguous.
Okay,
go ahead and you leave.
You know,
you can't say,
I'm so sorry I was late for this meeting.
I got here on time,
but I had to shit.
Yeah,
right,
right.
You can't say that now.
You gotta be upset,
you've got to go to the restroom and then you,
you know that the clock's running.
So cause if you come back 15 minutes later it covered in sweat.
They're like,
wow,
you took a monster shit.
Huh?
You can't really get that out there.
You're like,
oh fuck now I got to grind this thing out.
Question.
Sometimes that's what you have to do.
Sometimes you have to take a 10 minute heater.
Like sometimes you just,
you take a shit and it comes up clump,
clump,
and you're like,
God,
there's a lot more up there.
God Damn,
it happened on the flight yesterday.
Oh No.
As soon as I sat down and was to wanting to go to sleep and I was like,
I gotta take a shit.
And it was during takeoff.
So then you're like waiting for it to hit 10,000 feet,
you know,
and then you're,
you're waiting for them to turn the seat belt sign off.
And I go in there like this is going to be,
this is like a fucking marathon shit.
But I didn't have time for it.
So I really dropped half of it off,
just like a fall asleep and then later on I finished.
It was,
it was pretty,
pretty dramatic.
It's one of the weird things about your body is that there's like this
intangible sense of how much shit is in there.
You know,
like when you're taking a shit,
like you have that feeling,
that weird feeling like I smell a shit or I feel shit bro.
And I feel a shit cooking in the oven.
And then once you're taking that Shit,
you've got this pressure thing.
Like,
you know,
it's in there and you know,
it's up there and there's a certain amount.
I God damn,
and this isn't ready.
This is tied it.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm going to have to,
I'm going to have to up to empty it and then I'll come back later.
Yeah.
And that's,
and that's the worst you'd like when it's all gone.
Yeah.
Certain foods to will trigger,
um,
just amazing amounts of shit that come out of you where you're just like,
is my body mostly shit?
Like,
am I just a walking talking shit machine?
Because sometimes I'll like the amount that will come out of me.
It's just incredible to me.
I cannot get over what's coming out of me.
If you think about how much food you eat though,
if you sink,
sink,
think of like your entire day.
If you shit once a day thinking about breakfast in there and then lunch in there
and then your dinner in.
They're like this giant mound of food that goes into your body and then snack,
like you might have a protein bar along the way and then you'll have all this
you drink thing.
You might drink milk which has got some solids in there and then slowly but
surely compress that into just laws.
Big ropey shit logs.
It's amazing.
It's not really bigger.
Now picture a pretty girl squatting over your face and letting that all over
you.
Well that's the under glass like big thing guys.
Some guys like women shitting on class coffee tables.
Yeah,
I would always heard that about Stallone.
Those,
it was like one of those rumors probably made up.
It was probably like the Richard Gere durable thing.
Someone decided to say it and then it sounds cool.
So people repeat it.
Yeah,
we'll Stallone likes,
she likes to get under tables and girls take big juicy shits on those tables.
He loves him as he want to fuck them.
Just wants him to shit.
I'd like to watch people shit f over a glass table just to see it come out maybe
once.
Sure.
What about a guy like Joey Diaz?
I think that's the one that would be at the top of my list.
What if he fell and landed on a table on the table shattered and you died.
That'd be horrible.
Last went through.
Your next shit was in your eyeballs and you'd died knowing that shit was all
over your face and feeling the,
the hot blood rush out of your neck.
Wow.
That's already,
I slipped.
Whoops.
At too much sodium.
I think that it would be much more interesting to watch Diaz Shit.
Then some model.
I'd like to see him have explosive diarrhea on a glass table.
Well,
I would like to see a girl who's like addicted to stimulants,
like who's trying to be really skinny.
How?
Just how little she actually shifts in a day.
Probably shocking.
Seemed like a little tiny poops.
Curly squarely turned comes out slightly bile,
yellow smell to it.
What's going on June?
Sorry.
That's a big one.
Anything half of her shit.
His pills.
How do some stills come out?
Yeah,
like non dissolved pills.
Clumps.
Yeah,
but I mean it would be fun to watch a couple of times maybe why?
I don't know about fun but maybe fascinating.
Yeah.
Fascinating.
I think as an art exhibit you were talking about art a lot this weekend.
It'd be great to set up a live exhibit.
I've always thought of this where you have like 10 people 50 feet up and their
button a kid and they have different body types and they're sitting on glass
toilets with glass tubes coming down and then the exhibit as you walk around and
they all shit like that'd be kind of a fun and they flush it and you see these
glass tubes filled up with shit and come tumbling down and then you'd go septic
at the bottom,
a giant large tank filled with shit.
That's all glass.
And you have different colored hair and you're like,
I,
this is my creation.
this is if you wanted to buy this,
it's five 15 minutes.
We were uh,
talking with this dude who explained to us this weekend about,
um,
how,
uh,
we were talking about expensive photography because we saw this really expensive
photography piece and uh,
he was talking about the,
the scam or the strategy involved in the high powered,
high priced artwork and that what some times would a dealer will do is they get
a bunch of people that are really into,
uh,
to art and they,
what they'll do is they'll see these houses with people's art.
They'll like,
they'll take your breathe into the mica three coming to me.
One of you motherfuckers,
you know
it,
you might be a bunny.
Really?
Yeah,
I heard it several times.
You're freaked me out.
Anyway,
the guy said,
it's these things pick up lot.
Eddie Bravo was the worst.
He was like,
Oh yeah,
I forgot about it.
And we're like,
Hey,
you hear that?
Oh,
I didn't even hear that.
You don't hear that.
People hear it fucking Weirdo.
Anyway,
they take a,
a guy who like buys a lot of art,
they f they get these fish and they plant these things in the house.
We'd like to gift you this,
this gallery would like to give to you this piece.
This is a guy who a is pieces go for about $50,000 price point.
And seeing these,
you're uh,
you know,
you,
you buy a lot of work from this gallery or we think you would like it.
So we would like to gift it to you.
Like,
oh,
amazing.
Thank you so much.
And so then this gets around to these people that are in this small community of
people who buy expensive art.
Where'd you get that?
Oh,
it's a blah,
blah,
blah blah.
You know,
uh,
the uh,
you know,
Sebring,
a gallery actually a gifted it to me cause I buy a lot of pieces from them.
He's actually putting on an exhibit next month.
Oh,
amazing.
And then so they'll see these plugs.
They'll send like four or five.
It could be an unknown guy who doesn't have a price point really yet.
Exactly.
But he's talented.
Right.
And so that's how they sort of stimulate the environment and what he said in his
words,
create heat.
Yeah.
And so then they'll have a gallery exhibit and this guy's work will be up and
it's really good work,
but people are already bought into it because,
oh,
you know,
Rothchild has a piece above his bed.
It's $50,000 it's amazing.
Best part.
The part I was fascinated with is that if they get that out there,
right,
they see this stuff to these important people and then they have,
they make sure that the people that were gifted show up to the gallery so that
when other people with money are there,
that person's like,
yeah,
I have one of those.
Yeah.
Like,
Oh shit.
You have one of those.
It's weird.
Right.
I won't one of those too.
That's like the,
it's,
it's very strange,
man.
Yeah,
it's in,
it's,
it's kind of the fear,
I think the base of the fear.
Yeah.
As we talked about this exit through the gift shop is a exactly,
kind of the same mentality where the guy who was documenting Banksy was like,
I'll be an artist.
And then,
uh,
they create anybody successful,
crazy money.
And there's no like,
history of him.
There's no origin of,
of like work being built.
It was just one day,
it was like,
here's a bunch of work,
here's like an overwhelming amount of work that I kind of didn't really create.
And then everybody was willing to,
yeah,
well you can do that.
The market really interesting.
Yeah.
You can get to do that and you can just
can set people up.
I mean,
it's the hype machine.
It's like,
okay,
like how many times have there been like a comedy central special?
And you'll see the comedy central special common APP and they'll have a bunch of
people that,
uh,
you know,
our,
uh,
critics or something.
We'll say he's one of the funniest guys out there and boom,
go blah,
blah,
blah.
And then you have a,
you know,
you like someone famous,
I'll say something,
right.
My favorite all time,
comedian Pam.
And then you'll see this guy do this thing and then boom,
comma,
next.
It's the new show with the new guy already endorsed by all these other guys.
Essentially the same thing.
Same thing.
It's true.
You know?
Yeah.
Movies are big in that.
Fuck.
Yeah.
They are the core critics thing the whole way.
Like the funniest thing I've seen this year.
No,
no shows FiveStars blog,
this guy,
that guy,
this critic said,
I've never ever had such a good time.
He had a good time.
And you know,
there's some dudes when it comes to movies that you could just always count on.
There's some dudes that are just bullshitters oh yeah.
It's big bullshit business.
They just love shitty movies.
Yeah.
And then this other dude's like,
they'll criticize films like a Roger Ebert was a,
a famous Catholic.
People would be like really upset at some of the movies that he criticized the
way.
Criticized them.
Yeah.
I people put so much into what his,
um,
his critiques of films,
I never was really,
I've,
I've read a number of them.
Um,
I remember,
I don't remember which one,
but I remember disagreeing on some stuff he liked and I was like,
well I don't,
I don't really have,
I don't have a problem with that.
I just feel like,
um,
with the,
I really feel like everybody is a critic.
We all get to say what we like and don't like.
And like if you can find something that you line up a lot with their beliefs and
may,
that might be the person for you to trust.
But if it's not,
then like I don't give him really any more credibility than a lot of any other,
I know he watched a lot and you know,
they knew a lot about films.
Go Guy Myself.
You're what?
More of a Cisco Guy Cause Cisco like liked all those been movies and that kind
of Shitty Scifi movies.
So I never trusted him.
What does it,
you don't need those guys anymore.
The point is that everybody can do it now because of social media,
because of Facebook,
because of Twitter.
Anybody can be a critic and there's some pretty eloquent reviews by people who
don't do it.
For a living.
I've read many reviews that people like,
you know they have those,
a rotten tomato remove reviews.
Some of those rotten tomato reviews are really fucking good and they're really
concise and they're just regular folks.
Yeah.
So a person who enjoys the movie or didn't enjoy the movie and said,
here's what I think about this.
I think that that side is a better indicator because it gathers,
you know,
basically averages out.
You know like so have a lot of people that like that watch movies say this is
awesome,
there's a pretty good chance it's going to be a pretty decent movie.
Yeah.
If they all say this is a fucking garbage is that,
it's not very likely.
That's a good movie.
Yeah.
But then when you like take professional interviewers,
like there are professional reviewers,
like how can you be someone who'd just PR your art is reviewing other people's
art.
Cause that's essentially your contribution.
Your contribution is reviewing other people's are,
who the fuck are you?
And then you find out that eBird actually wrote his own script.
He made dog shit.
He made a dog shit movie he wrote.
And he directed a piece of fucking garbage.
So he failed at the thing that he was praised for being a critic of Valley of
the dolls.
Right.
Yeah.
All right.
I don't know if that is at the time.
Yeah.
It was supposed to be unbelievably bad.
You suck at it.
It's sexy though,
but it's like having the best,
like the most respected comedy critic was like one of the worst standups of all
time.
Exactly.
That's exactly what it's like.
But a guy who never got out of open Mike Nights
was fucking terrible.
He knows fuck.
And you know,
he would say,
here's the problem with Tom Seger is last special.
Yeah.
Tom has this pen dantic way of distributing as Joe,
so don't fuck fucking hack.
Yeah,
it's exactly that.
it is.
Well,
the idea of being a critic too,
there's only one reason why people become critics is because they don't have
anything to contribute.
There's no critics that our critics,
because you know,
I'm brilliant at writing books and I'm amazing at doing paintings and art,
but what I really like to do is judge other people's Shit.
That's my favorite thing.
Yeah,
no,
they usually want to be authors.
They want to be screenwriters.
They want to be someone who's doing that thing,
but they don't have it in them,
so they become a critic.
That's one of the beautiful things about things like rotten tomatoes.
They're just regular people.
They don't have to write a review of this.
They write a review of it because they're inspired to write,
which is probably like how you should,
we should,
we should treat artwork.
We should look at people's,
you know,
you look at an average,
old rotten tomatoes gave it 80% and then you look at the reviews and go,
okay,
I see what this guy's saying.
I said,
without giving away too much,
here's what I didn't like without giving away too much.
Here's what I liked.
Yeah.
Beyond the valley of the dolls,
the sequel,
and he cowrote it.
But I remember seeing it was sexy.
There was a lot of sex in it,
a lot of hot chicks and stuff.
But yeah,
it's total stupid stoner seventies movie.
We should watch it and get really high and do commentator Terry on it.
Russ Meyers beyond the valley of the dolls.
So this is a movie that he wrote,
he cowrote.
Uh,
it was a co written with Roger Ebert for 20th century.
See you can't criticize that though because unless you know who the other person
is any less,
you know what Roger's contributions where you know,
I mean he was a part of a dog shit movie,
but I've been a part of dog shit shows.
You know,
there was a lot of those things that we did on the man show that were dog shit.
But if you've know about the behind the scenes struggles to even get dog shit
made it realize how difficult it is to have to have something represent what you
wanted to do.
Especially if it was like his first movie he tried to make.
Who knows how many people were involved in this?
Who knows how high on coke the producers were,
who knows how fucking crazy the actors were.
Who knows.
It's so hard to tell.
And even if you read his copy of the script,
who knows how much editorial control he had on it over it.
Who knows?
Who knows what the studio decided they wanted added or removed.
It's hard until you,
unless you read their individual work,
like if you write a blog entry and you wrote it all by yourself,
you know,
now I know that's your work.
I know your work.
Right.
But like a show,
like,
like something like the Jessel neck offensive and how much control do you think
they had?
I mean,
how much,
how much input did comedy central have?
How much input did the producers have?
How?
Right.
Yeah.
I don't know the standards and practice people.
So you can't say this,
you can't say that,
change this now.
Waters it down,
but it's good enough.
Let's do it anyway.
Right.
Who knows?
You know,
I don't know why I chose to just on their girlfriends,
but I did.
Yeah,
no,
it,
imagine this,
it's a representation of what,
what he wants,
but you don't know that he's actually,
I mean,
getting on exactly what he wants all the time.
Right?
Yeah.
Which is the beautiful,
beautiful thing about podcasts.
And the beautiful thing about standup is you don't have to have something in it
that you don't like.
It can be exactly what you want.
Yeah.
It's limited amount of people are involved.
The smaller the number,
the,
the pure,
the division or the pure,
they're the product of what you're doing from one source.
It's weird when you,
you,
you get like giant groups of people that are like all the voting and deciding on
what should be in a movie.
All,
you know,
putting their input on how a TV show should be,
what the monologue should be and it's not going to work.
Yeah.
Can't have that.
The only way those things work cause if you have the less people the better.
And that's why the things that don't have like directors who really proved
themselves and talent that really proves itself can get like they have that
power of less and less notes.
That's why that work is a lot of times better.
You know,
people aren't telling really Tarantino,
you got to change all this shit now he's,
he's getting it.
He's putting the movie out there that he wants to put out there.
Yeah.
You know,
so that's why it's good South Park.
Perfect example.
There's,
it's really Trey Parker,
one fucking guy and Matt stone is involved in it as well.
And then all the writers are involved as well.
But without having this one guy,
if you've watched that a one hour thing that they did,
what was it called?
The countdown to a 77 days to air.
Really fascinating.
Really?
Yeah.
Really fascinating because you get to see his,
um,
his,
uh,
process,
the creative process.
Well,
how many other people input things and what's involved in the creating of
things,
but their show is so successful,
successful,
and so awesome that comedy central just leaves it alone.
They just,
it's so great back away as,
as the daily show,
that same sort of situation,
they don't fuck with it.
They just leave it alone.
And then Louie has that famous deal where he just takes less money and gets
known.
He delivers an episode goes,
they don't even know the episode.
Beautiful.
He just drops it out.
Here's the episode the best way.
And we'll look,
you know,
when you got a guy who is as talented as Louie,
like if you want them on your network,
the the best way to get them on your network is this.
Get Him,
get,
let him do it.
Let them do it.
They're smart enough to get out of their own way.
Right.
It's a beautiful thing that they figured out to do that with him,
to just step back,
get out of their own way and let him do it.
And unfortunately,
I feel like,
you know,
a lot of entertainment would be a lot better if they would embrace that a little
bit more.
You know,
there's so many people giving their input on,
on television.
I mean,
people would die if they realize the amount of people telling you to do things
and cut things out and TV.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
It's just,
um,
it's,
it's hard.
It's hard to get things done on a,
a network,
you know,
because every spot that they have is valuable.
Every slot,
every 30 minute slot,
especially during prime time.
It's extremely valuable.
It's worth so much to have those things there that they have to be real careful
because if it's a hit,
they can make so much money in advertising.
If you can,
you have a new Chappelle show and it becomes a new cultural icon sort of a
thing.
Oh my God,
it's worth money.
So much money.
So because of that,
these noncreative fucking people get involved in the creative process.
Try to optimize money.
Fuck that all up man.
But that's the one that went to walk away from and leave alone the most when we
did opie and Anthony on Friday,
they were talking about that about radio being sort of ruined because of uh,
all this input that now all this restrictions,
all this you,
you can't just be wild anymore.
You can't just do,
what you actually want to do is say what you actually want to say.
You've got to worry about being suspended.
You got to worry about being fined even on satellite radio there were still
find.
Yeah.
And then you get,
and they have like taboo topic,
like don't just don't even bring this up ever.
Yeah.
I mean they were,
they took a hiatus from satellite for a while,
but there were still unregular radio.
Yeah,
that's so bananas.
And if they,
the hiatus was because the,
they had on some crazy homeless guy get on and say he wanted to rape.
Uh,
who was it?
The black one.
Condoleezza Rice.
Oh right.
This is some crazy homeless guy saying a bunch of hymnody shit.
And because of that they got,
I'm pretty sure they got suspended from satellite,
but they were allowed to be on a regular radio.
It doesn't even,
it wasn't that what does,
let's see.
Opie and Anthony suspended from satellite radio.
I know that the playboy radio on Sirius radio,
which is now I think vivid radio,
they used to have up to,
like a month ago,
they had these rules that you weren't allowed to talk about incest.
You weren't allowed to talk about drugs including marijuana.
You weren't allowed to talk about all this shit.
And it's like,
wait,
this is playboy radio and you can't talk.
No.
Wanna XM suspended them for 30 days.
That's ridiculous.
Can't talk about marijuana on playboy radio.
Fuck fucking stupid shit.
Is that,
that's so dumb.
So they were on censored radio while while they were suspended from uncensored
radio.
That's so crazy for something someone else said.
That's so great.
Yeah.
Well it's more,
more idiotic thinking.
There's a lot of idiotic thinking out there,
but you know,
it's also,
let's be honest,
it's idiotic to have some fucking homeless guy on saying he wants a rape
Condoleezza Rice.
Like what you should do is say,
don't do that anymore.
Cause it's stupid and gross that that guy's nasty.
Like,
why?
Why do you have this fucked up mentally ill person in your studio saying stupid
shit like that?
Like that's not good.
Right.
But it's,
it's suspending them for that,
you know,
just,
yeah,
just don't do that again.
The people let you know,
the people should let them know that they don't like that.
Like,
hey man,
that was fucking gross.
Yeah.
Why?
You got this guy saying he's gonna rape some woman and this woman who works in
the White House,
like that's crazy.
How old were they suspended for 30 days.
30 days.
If it wasn't for though,
I would have never done this.
You know,
and we'd never done it this way either.
Cause every other show that I ever did,
every other radio show that ever did was always like real structured.
Like you would go in there,
they would have their bits,
they would have their news guy that would interrupt every 15 minutes.
They do their traffic thing.
They had all this stuff that you had to go through and do.
But when you do opie and Anthony,
he would just sit there and hang out with them.
Yeah.
It was just a slow,
just a loose,
open hang conversation.
And it was so much more fun to do that way.
And I remember doing it thinking like,
God damn like this is the way to do it.
Why don't they fucking do this?
I have a radio show and you still will sometimes every once in a while we'll
stop in and do radio somewhere else.
Right.
You'll still like if somebody,
if it in a certain town we still give them besides aside from ONA or,
no,
I think,
I think I do,
um,
ONA and Kevin and being regularly and you know,
I'll see.
Sometimes I'll call in to a another station.
There's not that many of them anymore.
This,
they did jocks.
These disc jockeys had been all choked out.
They'd been choked out by Jack TV or Jack Radio and all the preprogram was
Ambien Jack Radio.
It's pretty sweet though.
Have you ever listened to it before?
It's just music.
There's no g deejays anymore.
There's no radio personalities and the point.
Yeah.
And so it was morning radio shows are all just chill out some radios,
so,
so God damn awful to do.
But if you want like good music and you don't want to listen to fucking idiots
Babel,
which is a lot of what you get on those morning shows.
Yeah,
something like jacket is great.
Oh yeah,
no,
I'm saying like it's,
some of it is so like the guys doing morning shows,
some of them are still so bad.
They're dinosaurs.
Yeah.
They're there.
Done that.
That whole style only existed when there was a small amount of people that were
allowed to broadcast.
Yeah.
You know,
and then when the restrictions came down and they had to be as generic and as
politician,
like as possible,
they beat you,
you got this top 49 cents.
We have people who talk like this,
our next gas.
Do you know,
you're,
you're talking in some weird fake robot voice.
You're plugging in to this system and doing,
you know,
what's expected of you and there's no individuality to it.
There's no uniqueness to it.
There's a,
there's,
it's just a,
it's too restrictive and environment for creativity.
That's why when a guy like Howard stern came along,
it was just like he blew the roof off of the business because all of a sudden
the guy came along that wasn't scared to talk,
to take on controversial stances to say outrageous shit,
to say really funny things and to try to entertain people.
And that's really bold and crazy way and an attack.
Other people who were like his competitors like openly attack them.
Like,
who the fuck ever did that?
Yeah.
That was his,
that was also a strategy.
I didn't know her,
but it was like he would,
when he was new in a market and a radio guy was telling me that like if he came
into a new market,
the first thing he would always do is attack that guy's show so that like he was
playing in a new city and the,
the former number one show would have,
would be making,
being made fun of on Howard show so that listeners would be like,
oh shit.
Like he's making fun of this guy and create that,
that buzz in that new city.
Right.
It creates drama in the new city and then people are,
you know,
either saying like,
you know what,
he's right.
The show is fucking lame that we've been listening to or you know,
so you know,
he would also probably have,
but he would,
he would pull the people that were going to like him anyways from that new city
and then,
you know,
either worked out or it didn't.
And it's,
you know,
it's low fruit anyway because a lot of them really do suck.
Yeah.
So it's easy to do.
You can just go in there and Jack them cause it just pointing out the obvious.
Yeah.
Did a lot of these just he would play their show on his show.
Opiate Anthony does that.
They do that.
They,
what they do is um,
they'll,
they were doing a jock Tobar so uh,
throughout the month of October they were like really corny shitty radio shows.
They would highlight them,
play them and then just destroy them.
Oh my God.
Would play play an Anthony is so good at like destroying things and so as Norton
and so they would,
they would play these great and pause them and just crush them and just go off
on them for like 10 minutes and then come back to them and let them play some
more and then crush them.
Imagine how brutal like,
like if you're that guy and you hear that it's so fucking tight now that,
oh and they got ahold of your radio show today for John October and then the
past,
it's get ahold of you.
Oh cause the ONA past our fucking savages,
they're animals.
Those huge,
huge ONA fans listen to religiously every day when they,
when they decided to go after somebody over torture you on Twitter Tarci you're
fucking Facebook page.
Holy Shit.
Oh,
fucking attack you,
they'll attack you as well as during fans.
Yeah.
As,
I mean,
imagine like you,
you have your little radio show in De Moines and then you get home and you're
fucking mailbox is full.
You're like,
what's all this fucking hate mail?
Which is one thing I wanted to bring up.
Um,
we won the stitcher award for the best overall podcast and uh,
you know,
uh,
agree or disagree that that's all good.
But some was someone from some,
uh,
podcasts when I'm not even going to bother mentioning because I think it was
actually someone who is like,
one of the sound guys from the podcast told people that do this,
told people to send some hate our way.
And I got all these fucking angry people on Twitter that were angry that this
other show didn't win.
And look,
I,
you know,
first of all,
I think,
I think contests are stupid.
Okay.
I'm,
I'm glad that people like the show,
but I don't give a fuck if we won a contest.
I think contents are dumb as fuck.
I've never asked to won a contest.
Um,
it's nice that people acknowledge that they enjoy it.
I like that.
But if you're going after someone else for winning something and somehow or
another,
you know,
it,
you think it takes away from the show that you like,
you know,
like you're a fucking idiot.
Just a bigger show.
No,
no.
I've never even heard them until this,
this
wave of fucking hate started coming my way.
And then you just reading it,
it was like,
this is so stupid.
Like you don't have to like a show,
but if you're mad that your show didn't win and then another show did,
you're a fucking dunce and to just go out and push a bunch of hate.
All that means is that the show that you represent,
the show that you like has a bunch of assholes for fans?
It does.
I don't know why that is.
I don't know who's responsible for that.
But if someone necessary,
I mean,
we live in 2014 we on this podcast,
especially as a rule,
support other people as a rule.
I'm constantly telling people about other podcasts that I love,
whether it's hardcore history with Dan Carlin or um,
whether it's Danielle [inaudible],
Danielle Bell,
Ellie's podcasts or Thompson Jurez podcast,
or whether it's anybody,
Joey Diaz,
Ari Shaffir.
We'd constantly promote people's podcasts when they come on.
When Kara Santa Maria was on here the other day,
I was telling her,
start a podcast.
You should do a podcast.
And if somehow or another you like her podcast more than you'd like my podcast.
Good.
That means you like something.
I don't give a fuck.
There's plenty of people in this world.
There's 300 million fucking people in this country alone and this podcast
reaches people all over the planet.
I get emails and text messages into our tweets rather from New Zealand,
from Australia,
from Japan.
I get them from Afghanistan.
I get them constantly from all over the world.
It doesn't,
it is plenty of people.
You don't.
Cool.
Who knows how many millions that is,
that have access to podcasts.
You should listen to whatever you like.
You know the idea that somehow or another,
your show is a is,
is being stiffed by some,
you know,
maybe they had some,
they organize some fucking thing where they tried to win just the way that it's
possible that they were upset that they did that.
And so this is the blowback,
but it's probably that same sort of strategy.
Get us to talk about it,
get us to be angry about it,
and it pumps up that other show.
I had somebody try to bait us on that too.
I was like,
I'm not,
you know,
I hope that other show does great.
I hope it's something I can listen to.
I hope I enjoy it.
I'm not,
you know,
I'm not against any other shows.
I love what I love,
you know,
and if there's someone out there that wins some stitcher award or some iTunes
award or something like that and we didn't,
I'll listen to it because I want to know if it's good.
It's good.
Yeah.
You know,
maybe it'll,
I'll find it enjoyable and it'd be something I can listen to on a plane sometime
and have a good time.
I'm really sorry we got our listeners is sending you that.
Hey Man,
I was about to bring that up.
I was trying to work it in slowly.
Um,
we didn't,
we didn't even talk about the UFC.
Oh yeah.
Crazy ass fucking UFC.
That was pretty cool to fights.
I heard in the stance.
Yeah.
Heard some people got stabbed,
stabbed,
uh,
crazy.
Another guy threw a chair at a woman.
Did he throw it at somebody else and the woman got hit that what happened?
We didn't get clarity on that,
but it was,
it was intense in the stands.
It was funny because a,
it was,
how do you get a chair on the stance?
I think the chair was in,
um,
higher up when they have the,
the free standing area with like the,
where they're actually our chairs and there's,
Oh,
I see,
I see.
So there's still someone threw it down.
I'm not sure how it was thrown.
They were just talking about that a chair got thrown and hit a girl that a dude
through it,
but you know,
the stabbing,
it made sense that something like that happened because we were all,
I realized that sometimes fights happen in the stands and you look and it just
kind of,
if they,
if fizzles out really quickly.
And in this case it was,
um,
it was like,
you saw,
you heard a huge,
you know,
like kind of shouting,
screaming from this area and we all turned,
we're watching it.
And then I realized that 30 seconds later there's a fight going on and everybody
is looking in the stance like,
because it's,
there's so much action in there and people are scared.
What fight was going on while this was happening?
Man,
this had to have been,
um,
oh,
was Jamie Varner enabled through Hilo?
Was it that fight?
That's what someone said.
Um,
it was,
yeah,
it was later on.
So it was,
it wasn't one of the early fights.
I want to say.
It's probably about,
uh,
yeah,
that makes sense.
Six,
seven fights in.
So that would be furniture.
You thought it was a crazy fucking fight.
That fight makes people want to stab people.
Yeah.
And that was the,
that was bananas.
We're looking at six or seven decisions in a row up to that point.
And,
but Jamie Varner and able to Hilo just fucking assaulted each other.
They threw down,
Varner looked like,
um,
in the beginning,
like he was,
seemed like he was moments away from closing it out.
He hit him hard and fast and he had him in trouble and you just didn't know if
he was going to close it out right then.
But then towards the end of the fight he looked like he was gonna get him again.
Well,
he had him in a north south choke to for awhile.
He,
um,
he burnt his arm out in the first round because he was trying to choke them out
with that,
a north south choke.
So he had them on the ground,
had a dominant position,
how to choke,
couldn't finish the choke,
and then they got up and we're fucking sling it knuckles at each other.
And it's,
yeah,
it was one of the wildest,
most aggressive fights.
The way I described it,
they,
those punches were like,
what'd you say about my mother punches?
That's the way I described it,
because they were just,
there was so ridiculous.
It was still like throughout the fights we were seeing a number of haymakers
thrown a lot of over the top running,
throwing punches.
It was pretty intense.
There was a lot of,
there was people complained about it,
like pumps.
It always happens online.
People complain.
But I thought there was a,
there was some,
some fights that weren't the most dramatic because they were evenly matched and
then went to decision,
but that Varner fight and then of course that fucking the,
the main event was a huge disaster.
Yeah,
the stoppage.
The premature stoppage.
Yeah.
It's too bad because,
uh,
first of all it's too bad because Hanan Barao looked fucking sensational.
I mean,
he cracked Uriah faber with this big punch and he heard them with a bad leg
kick.
Before that Matt kick was like a whip.
He cracked your ride with a hard leg kick and you can see your,
I have like a little bit of a limp to him right after that.
Like it was a hard kick and then he caught him with that big punch and had them
really hurt.
And so for him it sucks because he had Uriah really badly hurt and it doesn't
give him like this,
this definitive ending.
He was looking at the referee when he was like hammer fist and your wife wanted
the referee to stop the fight,
which of course look,
he's the champion,
he wants to retain his title.
It's worth a lot of money to him it's,
it's,
it's very valuable.
It's also a moment of,
you know,
a point of pride,
but he had your rial really badly hurt.
It would have been way better if you could finish them off legitimately,
you know,
if he finished him off like where there's no controversy.
But herb dean stopped the fight Kinda early,
but you know,
and herb sign like he didn't know.
Like what if,
what if he stopped the fight and Uriah,
like after a Hanan Barao got off of them,
rolls over onto his back and he's unconscious.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
he's getting cracked.
He's hurt,
he's wobbling,
he's hanging on and he just had his hands up and he's getting hit with punches.
I didn't think it was quick enough to stop the fight or I didn't think it was
bad enough to stop the fight.
But I'm not a refereeing man.
I'm not.
I'm not in there.
Right next to the guys he is.
And he made a bad call.
But it's because he wanted everybody to be safe.
It's the right call to make if you're,
if you're concerned with being safe.
Yeah.
This is the Jamie Varner able to Hilo fight.
Boom.
That's the punch that landed.
Oh my God,
that's crazy.
But the way they were winging at each other,
look at this.
They're winging punches at each other.
Oh,
Tree Hilo hit him.
So perfect too.
And he was chasing after.
True.
Hilo.
I mean,
it was,
the whole thing was so crazy.
It was a,
it was a cool,
like one of the wildest,
like Donny Brooke style fights,
one of the wild,
most slobber knocker fights I've ever seen.
It's one of the fight.
It's the fight that gets an audience excited.
That's the kind of fight that people are fired up about.
I feel sorry for you or I favor a little bit.
Yeah.
That he didn't have a chance to actually come back and he's a fucking durable
guy too,
because he might have been able to get out of that and survive and come back.
We saw with Frankie Edgar versus gray Maynard.
He was hurt even worse than Uriah Faber was.
But look,
he came back and he won.
We came back and he made a draw out of it.
Who was it that fuck was it Martin?
They got out of a crazy armbar.
Where was he at?
Uh,
putting it on.
Um,
no,
that was a,
Martin was putting it on and uh,
he,
uh,
put it on fucking Russian guy.
Yeah.
Maga Madoff.
Mike.
I met him.
Yeah.
That was a crazy fight.
First round,
he,
he dominated that dude on the ground and got a real good deep arm bar and the
guy was screaming in agony when he was trying to get out of it.
Like you can see his arms hyperextended screaming in agony and managed to get
out of it and actually managed to win the fight.
Yeah.
That was incredible.
That was absolutely incredible.
Seeing like,
get out of it.
Fuck yeah,
there was some,
uh,
some great fights.
Josie,
all of those are fucking beast.
And so is that kid Ricardo Lamas,
man.
Ricardo Lamas is a tough fucking kid.
Um,
we also saw uh,
uh,
Alistair and Frank Mir.
Yeah.
And um,
do that,
that knee to the face.
Yeah.
I have,
I know a friend,
so I have a really good seats.
I was like,
hey side.
And that,
that knee was right in front of us and you hear it and we saw Frank's eyes roll
back.
I was certain,
first of all,
this,
I just heard his jaw get cracked in half.
And I also thought because he stumbled big time,
I thought he was absolutely.
Yeah.
He didn't want to go down and look.
Frank Mir is a tough motherfucker,
man.
He's tough.
He's tough and he's experienced and the dude is just been there,
done that.
It's hard to take him out,
you know,
even to this day.
That's why I was so impressive that Josh Barnett took him out so fast in the
first round.
Frank's fucking tough math.
We already kept trying to,
when he was trying to win and he was getting,
he was getting hit pretty good.
Almost had to give it to you at one point in time,
but Alster popped out of it.
But you know,
maybe a frank God that earlier in the fight before he'd taken all that
punishment,
maybe we would have more strength.
It's incredible to be able to take that abuse and still be in it though.
Well Alster fuck conservatively.
You liked kind of admitted to it that he was worried because he had lost two
fights in a row and he wanted to make sure he played it safe and got the win.
By the way,
was it Trujillo that,
that um,
you asked something like your,
did it hurt and he was like,
I heard like a mug then.
Yeah,
he was totally honest about it.
I mean,
yeah.
All right,
so we ran out of time and we're going to turn into a pumpkin soon.
Uh,
Tom Segura on Twitter,
ladies and gentlemen,
Tom S,
e g,
U R A,
and the podcasts with his lovely and talented wife,
Christina Palicki is called your mom's house.
And it is in fact the shit and they do a live version of this podcast.
A lot of times they'll,
Tom and Christina will do gigs.
Well,
they'll do stand up and um,
then they'll also do the podcast and it's got a fucking huge following now and
it's beautiful to see you,
man.
I love,
I love that it's growing and expanding and that you,
you have these shows now and all these people know,
like all the stuff that you guys talk about on a regular basis.
So they were like really into it.
It's so much fun.
It's,
it's like it's a party and it's a,
it's a good time.
We're doing live podcast is like a whole different type of performance for us.
So we're doing it all over,
man,
San Francisco,
New York,
Houston,
Seattle.
If it's going everywhere,
it's beautiful and they're all free.
Of course.
Um,
at uh,
what,
what is the website to listen to?
Yeah,
we're on Itunes,
where you go to your mom's house,
podcast.com be you too full and a thank you to Squarespace,
squarespace.com.
Use the code word Joe and save 10% off your first purchase.
Thanks also to legal zoom.com.
Use the code word Rogan in the referral box at checkout and get some more
savings.
Thanks to onnit.com use the code word Rogan and save 10% off any and all
supplements.
Thank you everybody who came to New York this weekend.
We had a great fucking time.
It couldn't have been a nicer crowd.
You guys were cool as fuck.
And even though everybody had to get over a thousand,
people had to get upstairs through two elevators.
Um,
we mentioned at the beginning of the show that we're going to start late because
of that.
And everybody cheered and they were happy.
And we got,
we got everybody seated before the show started.
It just,
I couldn't,
I can't thank you guys enough.
It's just,
it's a real honor having people that are so nice and so cool come to our shows.
I
don't know how it happened,
but we're going to make sure that we continue to try to nurture this.
All right.
We'll be back tomorrow with Justin Martin,
Dale and Friday with Cameron Hayes,
a famous bow hunter.
And then,
uh,
it looks like my due Saturday with Pete Dominic,
who is a very funny standup and sometimes he's on CNN and he's also got a great
show on Sirius Xm as well.
So we've got a lot of shit coming up the fucks.
And we loved the,
we love you.
We love you.
Love Raul because Ma.